قام هو وثلاثه جنرالات معاه
بعمليه لم تسبقها اي شيء حتى في الجزائر
اللي هي فكره المعتقلات
جاءوا بخطه جنونيه وشريره
يهجروا كل سكان المدنيين حتى
يخنقوا المقاومه 1929 هجروهم ما تناسب
طبعا في الطريق خاصه الاطفال وكبار السن
اخيرا قررت اني اعمل الحلقه الاخيره
وهي قلت انا ابغى اروح ازور المعتقلت
الخمسه معتقدات الموت فرجعت البنغازي وانا
وانا والله يا عبد الرحمن لا ابالغ كنت
ارتعش ومدعور ومروح شفت الموت عيني عينك
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح هذه الحلقه جزء من مشروع فهم
وشرح الوطن العربي ازعم ان هذا وفهم
التاريخ الاجتماعي والسياسي والثقافي
يقربنا الى بعض اكثر زايد ان يوضح مدى
التقارب والتقاطعات لسكان الدول العربيه
من المحيط الى الخليج هذه الحلقه عن ليبيا
الدوله اللي بالكاد نعرف عنها شيء غير
القذافي عمر المختار واللي في هذه الحلقه
اكتشفت ان ليبيا الاسم هذا هو جديد استفدت
ايطاليا في عهد الاستعمار
في هذه الحلقه نبغى نعرف ما هي التركيبه
السكانيه لليبيا علاقتها بالدوله
العثمانيه وعلاقتها بجيرانها وكيف كانت
بدايه الاستعمار الايطالي لها يقول ضيفي
بعد ان بحث الموضوع لاكثر من 15 سنه ان
الايطاليين قاموا ببادات جماعيه ومعتقالات
كانت هي التمهيد لما حصل لليهود في
المانيا يقول اكتشفت ان الالمان لم يعجبه
بتجربه استعماريه مثل تجربه المعتقلات
الايطاليه في ليبيا الحلقه دسمه وضيف مليء
ومتمكن وباحث رصين في الشان الليبي صرف
حياته كلها في فهم ما حدث في ليبيا
الدكتور علي حميده استاذ رئيس قسم العلوم
السياسيه بجامعه
الامريكيه الحلقه تاريخيه علميه مهمه
مؤثره وفيها الكثير من المعلومات والمصادر
والمراجع المهمه اللي ذكرت في هذه الحلقه
ستجد المعلومات والروابط موجوده في نشره
فنجان البريديه الرابط في وصف الحلقه اما
الان لنبدا شدني حلقتين حقيقه مميزين
الحلقه
الاستاد التونسي
وكان مليء يعني كانه هو يبغى يعطي اللي ما
عنده قبل لا يغادر وايضا الدكتور كمال
يعني
عظيم وعالم كبير والحلقه كانت ثريه جدا
فعلا جدا ثريه
انا الحكم ما جاتني فرصه اني اشوف البقيه
لكن
واضح انك غاوي الموضوع
الحمد لله
وبعدين في صديق ليبي عمل معي مقابله
طارق طارق ايوه قلت لها اقصد هذا الاخ
السعودي انا سعودي اعرفهم كثير لانه
زملائي كانوا اخواني في الدراسه
وقال لي هذا هذا بلع قبلي وهذا بالان
بالنسبه للعرب مش بالجزيره بس العرب عنده
يعني ملايين الملايين ما شاء الله الحمد
لله جميل جدا لا يعني انا عندي مشروع
يعني يعني اعتقد انه مره مهم جدا لغايه
الاهميه وهو فاهم بعضنا البعض
فكثير من الدول العربيه يعني نعتقد اننا
نعرفها صحيح وفي الاخير نكتشف ان احنا ما
نعرف الكثير هذا الكلام صحيح 100% والعكس
صحيح حتى العرب الاخرين ما يعرفوا
السعوديه انقطع
كل ما يعرفوا بعض يعني عندهم تصورات عامه
قد تكون صحيحه قد تكون خاطئه تماما
وفهمنا البعض قربنا من بعض بالتاكيد هذا
هذا لا جديد فيها وايضا
فيه عدم المعرفه البعض البعض الناس لبعضها
وايضا فيه احيانا
شيء عجيب كثير الناس يسر على ارائهم مع
انه ما يعرفوا شيء ويسر على ان هذا والله
لا لا هذا هذا
لكن انت كيف وجدتني يا عبد الرحمن انا
مختفي شويه عن العرب الاخرين صحيح والله
انت مختفي جدا
لكن
فانا اقول لك انه يعني هذا المشروع مهم
بالنسبه لنا فكان
عملنا حلقه عن السودان
ممتازه للاخ غسان وكان لبق جدا لبق وكان
ايضا حلقتها مشوقه وما يقعرش كثير في
التفاصيل يعني كانت كتير مفيده ممتازه
رائع
وعن ذلك فقس يعني فكانت يعني مهم بالنسبه
لي مثلا برضو عندنا ليبيا المغرب تونس
الجزائر يعني
وليبيا من الدول اللي
بعيده عن فهمنا
مش غير بس يمكن اكثر الدول العربيه يعني
مجهوله فعلا يعني حتى انتكرت في وحده من
ان العرب يعرفون مثلا الاستعمار
الفلسطيني وهذا معلوم مثلا وعندك الجزائر
برضو كذلك بس يعني استعمار اللي حصل
لليبيا يعني يكاد انه ما حد يعرف عنه ابدا
لا لا ستجد معلومات مهمه كل ما نعرف يمكن
اقذافي القذافي ادريس وشوي وغرائبيته شويه
طبعا
العلم لكن
يعني هي يمكن العرب انا اتفق معك العرب لا
يعرفوا بعضهم ولكن ليبيا لا زالت مجهوله
اكثر
جدا ليه تتوقع الجزائر حظيت بهذا
الانتشار يعني والاستعمار حاضر في ذهن
العرب بينما ليبيا
هذا سؤال وجيه عبد الرحمن الجزائر
الحركه الثوريه طبعا عندهم موجات من
المقاومه المقاومه الاولى الامير عبد
القادر والمقراني بعد والمقاومات الاخرى
هزمت وهاجر
القيادات فيهم الامير عبد القادر واسرته
واتباع عائله الى دمشق
وعاشوا كثير منهم في دمشق كانت
المعروفه
انا اعتقد ان
وايضا في نفس السياق لما هزمت المقاومه
الليبيه اللي استمرت عشرين سنه
وحطمت
الجمهوريه الطرابلسيه اللي هي من اوائل
الجمهوريات في الغرب الليبي وفي العالم
العربي كله
هاجر منهم ناس الى دمشق وناس حاجه وعندكم
السعوديه الملك عبد العزيز كانوا كثير من
القيادات الليبيه وجدوا ملجا عنده مثل
السيد بشير السعداوي
السيد
صالح قارغني
نوري
القائد الليبي العسكري طارق الافريقي اللي
هو كان من اوائل رؤساء اركان الجيش
السعودي هذا كان من مجتهدات المقاومه في
ليبيا والجهات في ليبيا
انا اعتقد الاجابه
لان الحركه الثوريه
الثوره ما نسميها احنا في الثوره
الجزائريه اللي بدات
ضد الاستعمار الايطالي وكانت زخمها في
الاعلام
في الراديو في الجرائد في في التلفزيون ضد
السماء الفرنسي في الجزائر فخلا اصبحت
قضيه الجزائر الخمسينيات والستينيات هي
قضيه العرب
يعني فهذا يبدو انا اجتهادي هذا هذا خلى
ان احنا العرب بدانا نطلع عليها اكثر صارت
يعني قضيه الجزائر هي قضيه العرب الاولى
ليست قضيه الجزائر ينبحس
وايضا صعود الحركه المعادله الاستعمار
القوميه عبد الناصر والحركات الاستقلاليه
في في فتره زاهوها واندفاعها فالجزائر
كانت تمثل مثل فلسطين القضيه اللي هي
الحقيقه ليست فلسطين بس تمثل السجون
يعني تم تبنيها كانها هي قضيه العرب كلهم
والمسلمين
ولكن المقاومه الليبيه يعني هزمت عسكريا
للاسف الشديد في 1931
وكانت في تلك الاجيال الاولى كانت تفهم
القضيه الليبيه الخاصه في الصحافه العربيه
سواء في في مصر ولا في بلاد الشام والله
في العراق مثلا الحج اكتشفنا انه وكان
مؤتمر اسلامي ليس ديني في حسب ولكن كانوا
المجاهدين يحتكبوا المسلمين الاخرين في
الحج وكانوا يقوموا بالدعايه وبالتثقيف في
المساله هذه القضيه الليبيه بعد هزيمتها
خفتت وكانها نسيت لان جاءت قضيه فلسطين
والاحتلال الصهيوني طبعا لفلسطين تاريخيا
وصحيح الشيخ الشهداء عمر المختار يعني مات
متواضعا ورفض انه يشترى وهو شيخ مسن وهو
واقف ووقف تهادي صارت رمز للنضال الاخلاقي
والوطني ضد الهيمنه وضد الاستعمار وضد
الامبرياليه
لكن اعتقد بالنسبه الاجيال الشابه
فيلم مصطفى العقاد هو اللي خلى القضيه
اكثر
باجتهادي هو اللي خلى العرب تعرفوا
وحشيه وصعبه جدا
ومهمه جدا
وايضا عرفتهم بدمويه هذه التجربه وايضا
الوقوف النضالي لشعب صغير فقير
حافي
ولكن
بسبب صموده وتنظيمه وعقيده اسلاميه في تلك
الفتره
استطاع انه هو يعني يقاوم لمده عشرين سنه
وادت نهايه الامر لحسن تقديري اذا كان
الجزائر ماتوا فيها مليون ونصف في ليبيا
قد تنتج يا عبد الرحمن ان حسب تقديري
ما بين ثلث الى نصف الشعب الليبي مات في
خلال الاربعين سنه من هذا الاستعمار
الدموي يعني اعطيك مثال
حسب الاحصاءات العثمانيه
1908 1910
تعداد تونس كان مليون وليبيا كان مليون
بين مليون مليون ونص
في 1943
تعداد تونس صار مليونين ونص
ليبيا
يعني تقريبا بالهاك يكون مليون
وين راحوا الناس طبعا كانوا يتزوجوا
وكانوا يسبوا اطفال وكذا لكن وين راحوا
هذا السؤال طبعا محدش يجاوب عنه
هذا طبعا يقود الى الى ليش ان القضيه
الليبيه
صارت لعند الان مجهوله يعني فيلم عمر
المختار كان مهم انا اعتقد مصطفى العقاد
مهما قيل عنه هو الحقيقه قدم برؤيه عربيه
اسلاميه لرمز بالرموز النضال الاستعم
وخلص الاف بالملايين من الشباب العربي
والمسلم والشابات ايضا يتعرفوا على جزء
دموي مهم ونظالي على القضيه الليبيه
الطليان المسليني والفاسست لان كانوا في
تخطيطهم انهم
اعتبروا ليبيا الشاطئ الرابع اللي هي
اسمها هذاك الوقت ما كانت فيه اسم ليبيا
ما في اسم ليبيا ليبيا روماني اسم قديم
اقرا في قبائل ليبو اصليه وفي قبائل محليه
اصليه قبل مجيء العرب في
الفتوحات بعد الفتوحات وبعدين طبعا عربت
شمال افريقيا
في فتره نسميها اللي هي الهجره الهلاليه
قبائل بني سليم وبني هلال اللي هو حول
تقريبا نقول قريب
يجي حوالي 500 الف بعد تقديرات 200 الف
اللي هم فيه نظرا نمطيه تقولون كالجراد
ضرب وكل شيء وانا اعتقد هذه انا تحديت هذه
النظره نظره صراحه مغرده جدا اللي صار
انهم عربوا شمال افريقيا لقرون طبعا
استمرت التعريب وطبعا عندك المكون الاصلي
اللي هو الامازيغ اللي احنا في الاول
يسموهم العرب هم يفضلون الاسم والامازيغ
هذا هم سكان الاصليين
وعمليه
كانت في حرف الاول ولكن بعدين ايضا دخول
الاسلام لها ليها تفسيرات كثيره مهمه جدا
وفي قبائل عربيه تبربرت امازيغيه وفي كثير
منظمه الامازيغ تعربوا او على الاقل صاروا
يتكلموا اللغه العربيه
واللغه الامازيغيه في البيت
فالتركيبه فيها يعني حيويه وفيها تعقيد
غير عادي
الان في طبعا مقولات اخرى تاتي عليها على
مساله
الاثنيه والاقليات انا الحقيقه
وكلام فارغ وتستغل لاسرائيل تبالغ فيها
كثيرا من حق المجموعات الثقافيه ان تعبر
عن لغاتها
وتراتها
ونعترف بالتنوع لا معناها مهم العرب لازم
يفهموا
لكن قضيه الاقليات انا يعني ضايقتني كتير
مفهوم الاقليه هو مفهوم اوروبي
احنا عندنا في التاريخ الاسلامي والعربي
الملل والنحل
وتاريخيا
الاسلام او حتى التجربه العثمانيه كانت
بكل تناقضات اللي فيها كانت تعترف بوجود
المسيحيين والمجيء واليهود ولاقليات
الاخرى
وبالتالي
تناول الموضوع من ناحيه العمليه مهم اننا
ننتقد
الاضطهاد اللي مبني على ضد اللغات وضد ضد
التقاليد والثقافات وغيرها لكن المفهوم
الحديث
الاقليه
ينطلق من منطلقات الاوروبيه والغربيه
بمعنى
اليهود
اقليا تاريخيه
معروفه بكل مقاييسها وفي الاخيرتهدت الغجر
نفس العمليه
احنا عندنا طبعا مطالب مشروعه لكن
التداخل العربي بالامازيغي بالطارق بحتى
تباوي لانه هم قليل حوالي 40 الف وخمسين
الف شويه لكن
الان بعد سقوط نظام القذافي صاروا كلهم
يقولوا اقليه يقولوا اقليات
فيوظف مفهوم الاقليه لاغراض اخرى وانا
اعتقد لا بد من التمييز بالاثنين المطالب
المشروعه الثقافيه واللغويه
والنظم الامازيغ انهم هم سكان الاصليين
هدول اصلا العرب اللي في شمال افريقيا
وبالتالي احترامهم مش كيف اقليه لكن يعني
فهموا من هذا السياق
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
الى تخرجت من الثانويه
على خلفيتي صحيح خلفيتي غريبه شويه يا عبد
الرحمن درست في جنوب ليبيا في مدينه سبها
لعاصمه اقليم فزان ومحافظه سبها فيما بعد
درست فيها في ودان درست حتى الثالث
الابتدائي وبعدين الوالد انتقل عاصمه فزان
ودرست فيها الابتدائي والاعدادي والثانوي
كان في نظام
جميل في العهد الملكي وفي عهد القذافي حتى
السبعينيات استمر يعني نفس اللي هي اوائل
الطلبه يرسلوا للدراسه بره بمنحه فارسلونا
بدل ما يرسلون لامريكا ولا الى اوروبا
ظهرنا وزير التعليم في ذلك الوقت مع
القذافي قالوا لهم اي حاجه في مصر ابعتوهم
من مصر فبعثونا لكليه الاقتصاد والعلوم
السياسيه في القاهره انا درست في القاهره
لمده اربع سنوات
بعدها رجعت لي قليله لفتره قصيره جدا
ومنها
جتني منحه للدراسه فدرست في مدينه سيئه
للغه ودرست الماجستير والدكتوراه
المنحه طبعا في الاخير للاسف مريت بظروف
صعبه لان
يعني قطعت المنحه الابتعاد
بحجج واهيه
لست ثوريا النظام يعرف به فقعدت ثلاث
سنوات وانا اشتغل وادرس
كنت باللغه العربيه
للامريكان واساعد بعض الزملاء باللغه
الانجليزيه لغايه ما خلصت
بعد ما انهيت الدراسه
في جامعه واشنطن
نشرت كتابي بعد سنه وهذا فتح لي افاق
والاستاذ المشرف كان دائما يصر على يقول
لي علي انتظر شويه ليبيا لن تختفي العالم
العربي لن يختفي شو رايك تقعد كم من سنه
عشان تعمق دراساتك وتاخذ خبره في التدريس
وبيني وبينك انا طبعا
كنت متضايق من النظام كتير من اصدقائي
واخواني امن خاصه كتاب وادباء اصدقاء
قريبين ليا وانا كنت ناشط في الحركه
الطلابيه سجن
لمده عشر سنوات فصارت حتى من ناحيه
من ناحيه شخصيه
يعني ليبيا صار بعكس ما كنت اتوقع اني كنت
ارجع واصير استاذ في في ليبيا تغير برنامج
فصرت اقول امي الله يرحمها كانت تقول لي
علي انت يعني ولدتك وانت سيبتني بعد
الثانوي وين رحت فنقول لها يا ام العام
الجاي العام الجاي العام الجاي لغايه
الحياه بعدين
قدمت في شغل ثابت يسموه تنير في النظام
الامريكي وفقت حصلت شغل كويس وبعدين صرت
وصلت استاذ كرسي رئيس قسم وجاتني فرصه
الحقيقه عبد الرحمن من لم يخطط لها بكل
امانه وهي
فرصه اني اتعمق
في البحث العلمي وتعلم التدريس الحديث
تدريس ليس ما معنى الواحد بس يدرس بس
طريقه طريقه حديثه تتعامل مع الطلاب وتاخذ
خبره عميقه
وتطور ادواتك
صرت بعد الامور سهلت شويه في ليبيا صرت
ازور كل عام
واحيانا يجيني دعوه لجنوب افريقيا دعوه
لمصر دعوه في الامم المتحده زي ما رحت
البحرين اول مره في زياره الخليج
ومؤتمراتي اوروبا في لبنان
في تونس فصارت جاتني فرصه اني ممكن اني
مشروع المعرفي
يمكن يخدم
يعني الاشياء اللي تهمني في ليبيا وفي
العالم العربي بوجودي في امريكا اكثر
ففجاه صرت اقول ان الحياه مرات يعني تخليك
تاخذ قرار من غير انت ما
ادري وما كانت صارت عندي يعني مساله انه
والله انا عندهم في هذا المجتمع الكبير
وغيره ما كانش عندي هذاك الرهاب او الخوف
الشديد يقول ارض الله واسعه
والواحد طالما انهم مستقل في تفكيره وقاعد
انه ينتج
ويصل اقصى درجات طموحات المعرفيه
فكانت موجوده في امريكا الحقيقه كان شيء
ايجابي كثير برغم كل كل الاشكاليات اللي
مطروحه فالكتب باختصار الكتاب الاول
والثاني والثالث اللي هو الكتاب الاخضر
اللي هو صدر ودي اعرف
اولادك كلهم في امريكا انا عندي اثنين
وعندي
من الاثنين
ههه
[ضحك]
عبد الرحمن
علاقتهم بالهويه الليبيه
هل
هل سؤال حلو سؤال حلو جدا انا عندي بنت
سميتها حنين
ناس يقولوا لي والله حنين الوطن قلت لهم
لا هو حنين
لاشياء مهمه بنتي حتى الان تدرس في
الماجستير في جامعه لندن
قالت لي بابا كيف تسميني حنين
قلت لها يا بنتي وانا طبعا اعطتني في
المحك قلت لها يا بنتي انا لما تفكرك انسى
الحنين
[ضحك]
لكن معليش انا سميتك اسم غريب شويه
والحقيقه يعني
وابني زكريا اللي هو ولد بعدها سنتين وهو
ربيتهم
كان كان اشكال كبير الحقيقه لكن ما حاولتش
اني حاولت اني اربيهم انهم يكونوا عندهم
يعني
المام ومعرفه بينهم يعني مسلمين وانهم عرب
امريكان ولكن ولد في هذا البلد او اني
اركز على الاشياء الاساسيه
ولكن خليتهم يكونوا منفتحين
وعندهم الخيارات بشيء تعمقوا فيها كما
يحبون ام لا ودرت في اشياء طبعا حتضحك
عليها شويه عبد الرحمن لكن لا امانع اني
اقول لك عليها مثلا قبل لا يناموا كنت
اعمل شيء اغني لهم بالعربي
[ضحك]
مثلا يعني
مثلا يا صباح الخير يا اللي معانا والا
ابني زكريا بيحب اغنيه البساطه البساطه
وترجمتها لي وبعدين طبعا اقرا لهم الفاتحه
فهم وهم صغيرين كانوا الفاتحه كويس
فبنتي الان قالت لي يا ريت تعمقتني اكثر
قلت لها انا اعطيتك الاساسيات لكن الان
انت مصره باش تتعمقي بادواتك وطريقتك اكثر
يتكلم العربيه
حنين بنتي يتكلم العربيه جبت لهم مدرسين
من البدايه كانوا في اسات يدرسوا اللغه
العربيه في جامعتي فاجيبهم للبيت عملهم
غدوه حلوه اكلي حلو
وخليهم يدرسوا الاولاد وهم صغيرين بعدين
شجعتهم في الثانوي وفي
الجامعه انه ياخذوا كورسات باللغه العربيه
طبعا في اشياء بسيطه ممكن تتحكم فيها
لاننا زوجتي امريكيه رغم انها يعني اسلمت
لكن المسكينه عربيتها مكسره يعني
كنت في الاشياء اللي انا احبها نحب
الموسيقى ست سنوات في ليبيا
وبالتالي احطهم الموسيقى العربيه في
السياره وفي البيت
كان الامل اني اروح لازور ليبيا كل سنه
لكن الظروف الصعبه السياسيه خلاط المساله
معقده شويه للاسف الشديد فكنتشف علاقتهم
بليبيا يعرف انفسهم بليبيين والله هم يعني
يقولوا احنا احنا اثنين يقولون احنا اثنين
قلت لهم شيء جميل يعني انتم
تشوفوا نفسكم ليبيين وامريكان عرب ومسلمين
لكن بيقولوا لي ان احنا نبغى ناخذ الجميل
في الاثنين
قلت لهم انا لن افرض عليكم
لكن
حنين لغتها العربيه اخذت جامعه النحو
والصرف وكان قالت المعقد جدا قلت لها حتى
احنا متاكدين منا يا ريت يدورونا حل
المبدعين ومدرسين اللغه العربيه في اللغه
العربيه انه يبسطوا قواعدنا شويه ويخليه
والله يعطونا وصفه سحريه عليها قلت لها
احنا حتى احنا نشانا كعرب معقد لينا لكن
قلت لها اصبر شويه توه الان طبعا تكتب
ممتاز
وتتكلم وانتاج مجرد تبي تحتاج تدريب اكثر
زكريا للاسف مقصره شويه لكن بحاول ان هو
يعني يذبحني بكلام مره مره يقول كلمه انا
يقول بسم الله ويقول السلام
فالحقيقه يعني يعني يزعجك هذا الموضوع
في الاول كان يزعجني لكن بعدين قلت انا
اعمل اللي علي
وربنا يوفقهم لن يعني اضع ذنب عليهم ولا
ذنب علي
انا هذا كان ودي اعرف يعني اذا ابغى اقول
شخص ليبي من هو الليبي
سؤال صعب جدا الاجابه عليه كل واحد
حيجاوبها بصوره
لكن انا عندي اجابه ممكن اكثر متواضع اكثر
وما هياش المتقاعره
هي الاحساس
طبعا هم يعرفوا مدى ارتباطي بليبيا ولكن
انا تربيت في في بالنسبه لي انا شخصيا لم
يسالوني تربيت في بيئه عربيه اسلاميه مش
بالصوره اللي هي الان الاسلام السياسي ولا
الشعارات والى الهواياتيه والا طلق اللحيه
والا غير لا ان احنا اهلنا وناسنا اللي
ربونا امهاتنا وامهاتنا وشداتنا انهم
يعني هذا جزء من تركيبتهم بشكل عام
ايضا اقول لهم على اشياء اخرى
ليبيا يعني طبعا هذه من ناحيه الدين طبعا
هو الاساس اللي هو انه احنا مسلمين ولكن
كيف الواحد انه يقول انا مسلم هذه طبعا
تختلف من شخص الى اخر انا اعتقد التجربه
العربيه الاسلاميه مهمه والتجربه انه
مرتبطه بكيان جغرافي
واكثر تحديدا يا عبد الرحمن اقول ايش ناكل
ايش نلبس اسم الموسيقى اللي نستمعها كيف
نتعامل مع الاخرين كيف مع بعضنا كيف
نتعامل مع الغرباء والدي الله يرحمه كان
طبعا في رمضان مره سالوني عنه كان في
رمضان على الافطار ياخذ اللبن والتمر
ويذهب الى المسجد في الحي
والبيت دائما يجيب مع الغرباء لبنانيين
مصريين تومانسه اخرين وجل وكانت كان عمرها
ما فرض علينا
مساله لكن يقول احنا العقيده اهم شيء
وحب المعرفه مهم جدا ولكن كانت اجمل ما في
الوارد الله يرحمه كان ممارساتها وتعامله
مش ايش اعمله كذا ولا اعملوا كذا انا
اعتقد لما اتكلم على ليبيا بالنسبه لي انا
طبعا تجربتي مركبه لاني عش طول حياتي بره
حتى في ناس قالوا لي غريبه انك لازم تتكلم
عربي قلت لهم صحيح لكن اهلي غسلوا دماغي
غسلوا دماغي
وتظاهر انه
كتمري مكتوب ولا شيء
طيب
انا بالنسبه لي الهويه هي مساله ليست
ساكنه يا عبد الرحمن عشان اضيف لك نقطه
اخرى وليست جامده
يعني متغيره
ولكن مرتبطه بالمكان مرتبطه
بالمؤسسات مرتبطه بالحياه اليوميه وانا
شخصيا هي
الذكريات الاهل الاصدقاء المكان
ولكن لا يعني الهويه ان انها تقعد في
السعوديه او في ليبيا اينما اينما اينما
تذهب وانا اعتقد دين القران في جوانب كثير
حلوه ارض الله واسعه يعني هذا مفهوم جميل
صديقي العزيز الدكتور الاستاذ ابراهيم
الكونيا وايضا جنوبي
كلي علي
الوطن يسكننا اينما كنا واينما نذهب وهذا
صحيح
فيعني يمكن يمكن يا عبد الرحمن انا مرات
اقول نفسي
اني احتاج ان
نستمتع ونقدر ونثمن الحياه اليوميه ان
احنا عندنا غناء ثقافي واجتماعي
ومعرفي
[موسيقى]
وعندنا الصراعات والاحباطات مثل ما الشعوب
الاخرى يعني الشعب الامريكي الان جيراني
وزملائي وزميلته اكتشفت انه عندهم مشاكل
الدنيا
وانهم زعلانين وانهم عندهم انكسارات
وعندهم
اكتئاب وانا كل شيء ان مرات احنا العرب
نجلد ذاتنا كتير نشعر بالدونيه كتير وكان
ما لم ننجز هذا الشيء او ننجز هذا الشيء
معناه احنا متخلفين
انا قاعد بالنسبه لي الان الامور اكثر
يعني صحيح جميل للانسان يكون طموح ويواجه
الفساد ويواجه التحميش ويواجه الاقصاء
ويواجه
الصراعات ايضا يعني الصراع مثلا الان في
فلسطين هذا نزعت قضيه كبرى
البشاعه والعنصريه النظام الصهيوني الان
اللي بحاول وايضا
ادعيه والمدافعين عنه بيحاولوا انهم يبروه
والله يخلوه انسان ان نظام عادي هذا شيء
شيء غير مقبول الفساد اللي صاير في
المنطقه في الانظمه العربيه
العنف اللي صاير طبعا مهم لكن ايضا
يعني مرات قلت زميل لي مغربي انا لا ابغى
ان العرب يغيروا طريقتهم احيانا اللي هي
عاطفيه ووجدانيه وكذا بعد ما يميزهم
وطريقه ضحكهم طريقه مبالغتهم طريقه
تعاملوا هذا جزء من حيوي فيها لكن
اعتقد ان ان
هذه الجوانب
اللي هو يعني اللي هي في الحياه اليوميه
مهم اننا نستوعبها واننا نستمتع بها وان
ايضا ناخذ حياه يعني لحظات من الحياه اللي
هي فيها كثير من السعاده والتقدير بدل
محاربه الطواحين الهواء او خلق شيء يمكن
هي مش احنا
فلهذا انا دائما اركز لا اركز على الدوله
العرب الان لان الان يقول لك الدوله بناء
الدوله وبناء الدوله والدوله الحديثه
وغيرها انا بالنسبه لي هذا اعتقد مبارك
فيه انا ادخل لازم نركز على المجتمعات
والمجت بشكل عاطفي
وسطح نحكي على بنيه التعليم الجيد
يعني الجمال
[موسيقى]
التمكين الناس
التعرف عليها
ان احنا صحيح
وعندنا تعدد يعني جهوي حتى من ايام
الاسلام لكن في نفس الوقت
في عندنا يعني عراه
[موسيقى]
وشائش
تخلينا يعني انتم في السعوديه واحنا من
ليبيا يعني زي ما اكتشفنا لما كنا مع
بعضنا في سياق اكتشفنا ان زملائنا او
زميلاتنا عندنا اشياء تتجاوز الحدود احنا
مسلمين وعرب وتربطنا يعني علاقات قويه
تتجاوز كل الاشياء هذه وانا اعتقد هذا
يمكن اللي يركز عليه في المستقبل وايضا
بجانب الجوانب الناقصه والاحباطات
والهزائم والفساد والقمر والاخصاء وغيره
والفرص العمل ان نبدا نركز على الجوانب
الثقافيه
الاشياء اللي تجمعنا
وايضا
يا ريت اننا نبدا نتعرف على بعضنا بشكل
اكثر عمقا واكثر
جديه
هذا يمكن يخلينا ان حتى المساله ان احنا
متخلفين احنا مش عارف ايش احنا
العرب صفتهم او موضوع وانا الحقيقه لا احب
اطلاقا اللي هي اجددات والشعور بالدونيه
واعتقد ان هذا يحتاج لاعاده التفكير
واعاده ايضا
التخييم
طيب اتذكر قبل شوي كنت تقول انه انت من
الاشراف نعم
بدي اعرف ايش المكونات اللي موجوده في
سواء الثقافيه والقبليه الموجوده في ليبيا
في الاشراف في الامازيغ في شوف عبد الرحمن
فيه تنوع زي ما عندكم في السعوديه متنوع
ومتعدده
ليبيا على صغرها عدد سكان حوالي سبعه
مليون لكن جغرافيا رابع دوله من ناحيه
المساحه في افريقيا ليبيا قاره كبيره
وانا اعتقد من ناحيه الجغرافيه متعدده
عندنا منطقه مثلا في الجبل الاخضر زي
عندكم في عسير في جبال
وخضره واشجار وغيره وغيره ومنطقه راس
الهلال ولا شحات ولا المدينه الرائعه
من اجمل المدن العربيه برايي على البحر
وعلى الجبل الاخضر وعندنا صحراء شاسعه
حوالي 90% او اكثر منها من الصحراء الكبرى
في ليبيا
عند المنطقه الغربيه الاكثر كثافه
من ناحيه الثقافيه والاثنيه في تعدد ولكن
في ايضا مش بشكل كبير يعني الغالبيه
الليبيين يا عبد الرحمن هم سنيون
مالكيون وشويه عندنا اباضيين في الجبل
الغربي وفي زواره
لكن الغالبيه العظمى
سنه
مالكيين مذهب والجي العجيب ان نذهب
المالكي هو المذهب المهيمن في شمال
افريقيا
منطقه المغرب العربي الاسلامي هو غالبيتا
سكانه مالكي المدى حتى الصعيد المصري يعني
على فكره يا عبد الرحمن هو مالكي لانه
عندهم
الشوافع وانتم عدديه في دلتا وفي القاهره
وكذا لكن الصعيد المصري ايضا مالك
المذهب وهذا طبعا مهم جدا
التركيب
السؤال في هناك طبعا مدن
وفيه يعني بوادي
وتاريخيا بحكم الجغرافيا والبيئه
دائما الباحثين الغربيين وحتى العرب الان
يحكوا على مساله تنظيم القبلي في ليبيا
وانا الحقيقه لا انا دائما اتاسف من هذا
الموضوع
لان
القبيله مكون تاريخي صحيح
لكن ينظر القبيله كانها
مفهوم سكوني شامت تسالهم ما الفرق بين
القبيله في بدايه القرن العشرين
والقبيله في بدايه القانون 21
هل القبيل هل مشاعل قبلي
واحد على الملكيه زائد كما هي هل عمليه
التحضر والهجره المدن هي تاثير ام لا هل
التعليم لهيدور ولا لا
هل التراتبات الطبقيه والفئويه ومن ناحيه
الثروه لتاثير ام لا هل اقتصاديات السوق
لها دور ولا لا هل القبيله مفهومها واحد
هناك قبائل تجاريه هناك قبائل شبه روحا
هناك قبائل روحا الان يعني الشعب الليبي
يعيش في خمس مدن كبيره 80% يعيشوا خمس مدن
كبير
ولكن
لا يستطيع الاجابه على هذا فتصير المساله
المجتمع الليبي هو مجتمع قبلي هم بدو شمال
افريقيا واحيانا دائما يشبهون بيكم
افاترول وعندهم اباديه مش متحضرين كثير
وانا اعتقد هذا هذا كلام غير علمي وللاسف
الشديد الان بعد 2011 لان هناك شهر رهيب
لا اقول في العالم العربي خاصه يعني الى
حد ما لكن الباحثين الغربيين كلهم من
المهووسين بقضيه القبيله
اصبحت مستقره في اقتصاد السوق الاستعماري
الراسمالي
والهجره للمدن العمل
وايضا
الاقتصاديات السوق استمرت بعد الاستقلال
والدوله الريعيه طبعا ادت الى يعني توطين
معظم القبائل
وصارت التركيبه اكثر يعني اكثر تعقيدا من
مساله ان القبيله
لان الناس يقولون اصلي مثلا
انا دوسري والا مثلا
زهراني والا والا مثلا يعني
حوثي وعلاء غير لدين يقولون كما في
السعوديه وكما في العالم العربي في مساله
عن التقرير الثقافي انه
اسمك الاخير يكون يا اما اسم القبيله او
العائله او البلده اللي ولدت فيها
عسيري مثلا عندهم كثير في السعوديه دوسري
شهراني عنزي
شمري احنا يقول لك والله
في النهايه يقول الشريف علي عبد اللطيف
حميده الشريف
او يقول لك معمر محمد بو منيار القذافي
والا
منير البرعصي البرعصي
لكن لا يعني ان الجداد فهو البراعصه
والاشراف من ناحيه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
هم لا زالوا كما كانوا خمسين سنه فاتم 60
سنه ولهذا
هرطقه
وكلام غير علمي وغير دقيق
[موسيقى]
نشرات بريديه متنوعه ذكيه وممتعه خليك على
الطلاع التخصص اللي يهمك والمواضيع اللي
تشدك وتساعدك تكتشف اهتمامات جديده تعرف
على نشراتنا عن الحياه اليوميه والافلام
والكتب حتى كواليس اشتركت اللي يناسبك
منها وتوصلك على بريدك مباشره نترك لك
رابط الاشتراك في الوصف
طيب انت تقول مثلا رموز الجهاد الليبي هم
الاباء المؤسسين
للهويه الليبيه الحديثه
بدي اعرف ايش الهويه الحديث
ه
هل هم عمر المختار والمجاهدين هذولا
لم عندما جاء جاءت الامبرياليه الغربيه
والاستعمار الايطالي تحديدا
جاؤوا غزو ليبيا في 1900 اكتوبر 1911
تقريبا حوالي 35 40 الف جندي وبوارج
عسكريه
المجتمع ليدا كانت ولا عثمانيه مثل العراق
ومثل مصر ومثل الشعب بلاد الشام وفلسطين
وتونس والجزائر حتى 1830 كانت جزء من
الدوله العليه العثمانيه او الامبراطوريه
العثمانيه وعندكم ايضا الحجاز وجزء من
اليمن
بقيه العالم العربي المغرب السلطنه
العلويه
او الجزيره العربيه تحت
التكوين المحلي اللي هو
اللي هو دوله الدوله السعوديه اللي هي
بنيت على مؤسسات
ونموذج محلي اسلامي
او اليمن في في اليمن ايضا مؤسسه بنيت من
خلال تقاليد المحليه الاسلاميه العربيه في
اليمن
فاعتقد ان
المقاومه انا اعود اليك الاجابه على سؤالك
لما سالتهم انتم انا ذكر قلت
لها
حاجه مبروكه قالت لي انا عليش فيك يعني
شنو مشكلتك قالت لي انا ليبيه انا مو
عربيه ومسلمه
انا اعتقد مرات ان سؤال الهويه سؤال نخبوي
قد اكون مخطي فيه عبد الرحمن
انا اعتقد الناس العاديين عارفين هم من
لكن النخب مرات تختلق في هال في القضايا
لاغراض
ممكن يعني دوافع ايئانيه لا تبصر عنها
بالنسبه لها مهمه للاسف الشديد طبعا
الحركات الاسلام السياسي ضخم مساله الهويه
اكثر
ضخامه اكتر
على اساس انهم صاروا هم حجاب والمتكلمين
على قضيه
الهويه عندنا
في ليبيا
اعود لك الى الاجابه الناس اللي هم طبعا
لقاومه الاستعمار
ومركز الجهات طرابلس والحقيقه هذا مركز
مهم جدا في العالم العربي المركز الوحيد
اللي جمع حوالي لا يقل عن يعني عشرين الف
او اكثر روايه شبهيه من الاحياء
فهم قالوا احنا يعني
شاهدنا وقاومنا الاستماع انا اعتقد اعطيني
مفتاح
لكن
كيف
ما هي المؤسسات ما هي
الجيولوجيات اللي طرحوها
لتوضيح من هم
وانا وجدت ثلاث ثلاث نماذج
معلش
نعطيك السياق العام بس الاجابه ما تكونش
ابيض ولا اسود
عندنا في حركه
تجديديه اصلاحيه عبقريه اسمها الحركه
السنوسيه اسسها عالم جزائري
اسمه محمد بن علي السنوسي في منتصف القرن
التاسع عشر
درس في مستغانم ودرس في جامعه القرويين في
شمال افريقيا عندنا اللي تعرفوها انتم
اكثر يمكن في المشرق العربي والجزيره
العربيه والازهر لكن في جامعتين اللي هي
جامعه الزيتونه في تونس
وجامعه القرويين
هذه الجامعات اللي هي العميق طبعا انا
براينا يجب ان تحضى كثير من الاهتمام بانه
مهمه جدا العجيب ان النخب المحليه ذا
مدرسه المدارس الفرنسيه او بالزيتونه او
القرويين حتى النقب في تونس وفي الجزائر
وفي
المغرب نفس المساله
فيها ابنائهم يرسلوهم يامل الزيتونه او
الازهر
الحركه السنوسيه باختصار لان هذا موضوع
غني ومهم
هذا
العالم الكبير اللي هو نعتبره من كبار
العقول الفذه في القرن التاسع عشر المصلحه
درس في القرويين وبعدها مر بالازهر ولكن
الازهر علماء الازهر لم
يرتاحوا له كثيرا وكان ذهب الى الحجاز
لماذا ذهب الى الحجاز لان استاذ كان
استاذا الكبير هو احمد بن ادريس الفاسي
هذا استاذ ايضا وتحت من تحت منا طلعت
الحركه المرغنيه والحركه السنوسيه والحركه
الادريسيه كان استاذ قطب ولم يؤسس حركه
رفض انه يؤسس حركه او طريقه
هذا
العالم محمد بن ابي السنوسي ذهب الى مع
استاذه الى الحجاز ومن الحجاز الى اليمن
تلامدت الادارسه اللي في عسير بعض منهم
اللي هم كانوا في عسير وفي السودان وفي
وفي مصر
المهم بالنسبه للسنوسيه ماذا ماذا حدث حتى
نضبط الموضوع ونخليش يريح منه
اولا كتب كتاب
ينتقد فيه
اغلاق باب الاجتهاد ويدعو الى عاده باب
الاجتهاد
وضح ان هو مش بس عالم دين ومجدد
عنده فكره نبي بيكون حركه اجتماعيه
مبنيه على التقاليد الاسلاميه التقاليد
المالكيه الصوفيه
المؤسسات الزاويه وركز على شيء عبد الرحمن
الاكتفاء الذاتي والاعتماد الذاتي على
الذات والتجاره تنظيمها وايضا التعليم
وكانوا اتباعوا من جميع انحاء العالم
الاسلامي بما فيهم من المدينه
من عسير ومن اليمن ومن مصر ومن السودان
ومن المغرب ومن تونس ومن الجزائر
الاخوان وحتى ايضا الاتباع يسمى الاخوان
واستطاعت هذه الحركه
لان وجد في ليبيا بعيده عن عن عيون الدوله
العثمانيه فجعل الصحراء الليبيه في
البيضاء الزاويه الاولى وبدا يكون في
الزوايا
ومنها
بدات حركه اقوم طريقه متقدمه جدا انا
برايي كانت حديثه
واستطاع انه ينظم التجاره والقضاء
والتعليم
والتنظيم الاداري وكون معهد عالي في مدينه
واحه مجهول
هذه الحركه ايضا لانه ولدت الجزائر
والمساطيع العوده للجزائر بدات في التكوين
والاعداد التنظيمي
الشيخ عمر المختار وحتى اتي الى الاجابه
هنا هو احد تلامذه هذه الحركه وتعلم في
زواياها ومعاهدها
ولهذا عندما جاء الطليان الى غزو ليبيا
واجهتهم
مقاومه مجتمع منظم
وكانت كل قبيله تعطي متطوعين وزادهم
واكلهم وبنادقهم ولما يستشهد احد يبدلون
بمتطوعين اخرين ولهذا طليان استمرت
المقاومه ضد مجتمع ليس قياده يعني فحسب
لمده عشرين سنه
بالنسبه الى
في غرب ليبيا القيادات
كانت تركيب السكانيه والديموغرافيه
الاجتماعيه المركبه هناك يعني تعداد اكبر
ثنتين سكان ليبيا في الغرب ليبيا
ومدينه طرابلس هي طبعا مدينه الاكثر
يعني
هيمنه من ناحيه الاقتصاديه ومن ناحيه
الاداريه والبنوك والمعاملات والاداره
والقضاء والتعليم وغيرهم
والقيادات في المنطقه الغربيه
جاءوا بفكره كتير رائعه وهي تكوين جمهوريه
جمهوريه سموها جمهوريه طرابلسيه ولم
يتفقوا على قياده واحده فكونه قياده
جماعيه من اربع كيلات
الطليان وبعثوا رسائل الى القاده الغربيين
والعالم الاسلامي باعترافها
لم يرد ايا من القاده الغربيين والامريكان
على على رسائله
وكان عندهم مفتي وكان عندهم يا سيدي جيش
وكان للنظام اداري وكانت في رؤيا متقدمه
جدا
الطليان طبعا دمروا عسكريا هذه الجمهوريه
الوليده
سقطت بهذه السرعه هل لضعفها لان
القيادات كانت ايضا بينها توازن ولكن
بينها خلافات
واستطاعوا انهم عسكريا يضربوهم ضربه قاسمه
وايضا استغلوا بعض قيادات ضد بعضها يعني
عمليه
تلاعب بالقيادات والشراء بعضها لكن عسكريا
يعني جاؤوا بجيش قوي جدا
واستخدموا الطياره استخدم الطياره اول مره
في ليبيا في التاريخ الحديث
وايضا
استخدموا طيران لملحقه المجاهدين
وفيما بعد الغاز السام لاول مره في 1929
كان دائما
المقاومه ترجع الى التخوم والى الدواخل في
الفزان
لكن القيادات الغربيه في المنطقه الغربيه
وانا اعزوها الى الى تعقيد التركيبه
الاجتماعيه
والصراع بين الزعامات السياسيه رمضان
المريض عبد النبي بالخير
والزعيم الكبير
[موسيقى]
سليمان الباروني
يعني هو من اصل امازيغي ولكن قاعد كبير
وهاجر لعمان لانه اباضي
واصبح مستشار من
لسلطان عمان كما صار بعض المهاجرين
الليبيين بعد الهزيمه مستشارين للملك عبد
العزيز بن سعود وعاشوا في السعوديه واخرين
اشتغلوا في سوريا ولبنان
اللي صار عنا
والتركيز على هذه التجديد في هذه واستخدام
المؤسسات المحليه هو الحقيقه ادى الى قيام
دوله من غير ما يعلموها
الطليان كان وحيدهم
ولكن
من الناحيه الرمزيه والمؤسسيه
بعد بعد استشهاد شيخ الشهداء عمر المختار
وقتل
ونفي كثير من الالاف من الناس اللي كانوا
في المقاومه بها فيهم يعني جديد جدي
الوالدي ووالدتي كانوا في المقاومه وهذا
يمكن سر اهتمامي انا بهذا التاريخ تحديدا
من البدايه
المؤسسات السنوسيه
اعطت يعني زي ما يقول
التشيؤ او الاصول المحليه لدوله الاستقلال
فيما بعد
الجمهوريه طرابلسيه ايضا عطتنا نموذج اخر
للمقاومه
وعندما هزمت الفاشيه الايطاليه في 1943
لانها تحالفه مع مع هتلر ومع النازيه في
المانيا
بدات اللعب المنفيين الليبيين سواء في
دمشق سواء في القاهره سواء في تونس وخاصه
الجناح اللي كان فيه في في دمشق كانوا
على درجه عاليه من الثقافه والتعليم
والكفاءه فبداوا في تعبئه الراي العام بما
فيها استخدام الحج اكتشفت ان الحج مثلا
كانوا يوزعوا في منشوراتهم
في خطب
وبتعاطف طبعا
السلطات في الحجاز وفيها بعد الملك عبد
العزيز تلك الفتره يعني بعدها مباشره ولكن
في نهايه الامر
يا عبد الرحمن لما هزمت الجمهوريه
الطرابلسيه مؤتمر غريان
قرر ان يقبلوا بان بايعوا منذ بدايه
العشرينيات انه يكون امير مسلم
يكون هو يقود
الاستقلال يعني انا الليبيين وحدثهم شيئين
الجهات من اجل حق التقرير نصيب ضد
الاستعمار الايطالي
فيما بعد طبعا اللي هو مساله اعتقد في بعض
الاستقلال هي مساله المسابقه القانونيه
والاجتماعيه والتنميه يعني السؤال
الوطني العام والسؤال الاجتماعي
لكن اختلف فيها اشياء كثيره
وبالتالي اعطوا البيعه الحركه الثلاثيه
لما ضرب فيها الجناح العسكري والمقاوم
والاف بما فيها طبعا الكتاب الاخير اللي
هو
عن
معتقلات اللي هو حناتي قليلا اتمنى هذا
لكن
بدا
الامير محمد ادريس السيد محمد ادريس
السنوسي اللي هو حفيد السيد محمد بن علي
السنوسي
يعني الفكره هنا لازم نكون واعيين ان
الحركه السنوسيه لم تكن شوفونيه مثلا من
ناحيه لازم يكون ليبيا والا لا اتباعها من
جميع انحاء العالم الاسلامي وايضا
[موسيقى]
قامت بدور تعليمي وتنويري في نشر الاسلام
بطريقه بديعه في غرب مثلا في تشاد في غرب
السودان في شمال نيجيريا في النيجر انا
اعطيك مثال بسيط
وانا دائما احب هذه الاشياء العمليه مثلا
اسم السنوسي تجد
في شمال تشاد في النيجر في
جزء من غرب السودان وفي ليبيا حتى في
الغرب
الليبيسيه انتشرت بشكل عميق في الشرق
الليبي وجنوب الليبي وفي تخوم المنطقه
الغربيه لان الدوله العثمانيه كانت قويه
بمؤسساتها فلم تتغلغل في الجوانب بالمدن
الحضريه في الغرب الليبي كيف كانت علاقه
الحرك السنوسيه مع الدوله العثمانيه شائكه
وايضا متغيره
الدوله العثمانيه
كانت تنظر بعين الريبه وتحاول
تسيطر على الشرق الليبي ولكن من الناحيه
العمليه السيد محمد بن السنوسي اختار تخوم
وداخل شرخ ليبيا لان الدوله العثمانيه
ليست لها يد قويه هناك ونفود كبير ولا
عندما صارت قويه صار اي نوع من التفاوض
اعثوا من الضرائب الزوايا السلسيه او
المساجد
شمال افريقيا
من الضرائب
العثمانيه
ولكن كان هناك نوع من التوتر وكان هناك
ايضا
مبعوتين عثمانيين الى الكفره العاصمه
الثانيه وفيها بعد في عاصمه ثالثه في تشاد
لان طبعا رؤيتها يعني اسلاميه الجامعه
الاسلاميه بشكل عام فاللي صار ان
الدوله العثمانيه كانت علاقتها باعتقاد
مبنيه على
التهادن فتره ولكن التوتر فتره اخرى
وعندما هزمت وجعل الاستعمار الايطالي بدات
التحالف
ما بين
السلوكيه والدوله العثمانيه يعني واجهوا
عدو واحد ولهذا
الزعيم الثالث للحركه السنوسيه وهو ودفن
في البقيع عندكم في الحجاز شخصيه عظيمه
ومناضله اسمها السيد احمد الشريف السنوسي
ابن السيد المهدي السنوسي اللي هو ابن
المؤسس الامام محمد بن علي السنوسي طب ليش
اعلن عن وجود الدوله السنوسيه في 1913 وش
السبب بعد هذا كله يعني هي بدات في منتصف
القرن التاسع لان اعتقد كانت اولا الحاجه
الى اعلان دوله انذاك يعني هل كانت لتجمع
الناس ضد في مقاومه ضد الاحتلال الايطالي
المقاومه طبعا جمعت المساله وبعدين ايضا
لان
منظمه الشيوخ
والمجاهدين جاؤوا ليس من القبائل اللي زي
ما تقول المرموقه والعليا
من القبائل المراطين
والجماعات الاخرى وصار فيه نوع من التمازج
بين الاثنين على الكفاءه والقدره العسكريه
والقدره المعرفيه
وبالتالي
لما هزمت الحركه السلوكيه طبعا عمر
المختار
اسر وايضا حكم وشنق
امام الناس استشهد الناس وعشرين الف في
نفس الوقت
الامير محمد
ادريس السنوسي
طليان بعد ما هذا اماره اماره وصار امير
وصار اعترفوا
لا معاهدات ولا قانون اساسي ولا حكم ذاتي
ولا يحصلون ليبي هاد لينا جزء من ايطاليا
كما كانت في ايام الحكم الرباني فاستغلوا
المساله هذه فبداوا عمليه بشعه وعنيفه
ودمويه لضرب اخر جيوب المقاومه اسمه هذا
المكان
من قبل وفاه او مقتل لكن
الفاشين جاءوا بعنف وجعوا بسياسه اكثر
جيوش اكثر تسليحا وعددا
واضطر السيد محمد
ادريس السنوسي ان يهاجر الى مصر
صارت فيه نوع
التباين في وجه النظر السيد محمد الامير
محمد ادريس سنوسي قال لابد من التفاوض
والاعترافي ان الوضع الان صعب ولكن ايضا
ايجاد حليف اخر
الانجليز
والانجليز ايضا كانوا يهمهم انه يكون
امنهم في مصر مضمون لان يخافوا من توتر
الجبهه الشرقيه الجبهه الغربيه
فكانوا يحتاجوا الى وخاصه ان السيد احمد
الشريف السنوسي اضطر بضغط عثماني انه يهجم
على مصر ايام الحرب العالميه الاولى
وطبعا كانت تصرف في البدايه بعض الضباط
المصريين
واحتل جزء من
رباحات
والمنطقه الحدوديه ولكن الجيش الانجليزي
ضرب بعنف وهزم فصار يقول جيش جائع وانتهى
به انه هو الطليان والانجليز فرضوا في
المفاوضات انه هو يعني يطرد من ليبيا
وهاجم على مصر باسم الجيش الليبي لا يعني
كان باسم الاتحاد في العثماني العثماني
كانوا انور باشا مصرين انها لازم يكون في
الجيش العثماني من فلسطين
والقوات العثمانيه والسنوسيه تهاجم على
الوجود الانجليزي في مصر هذه كانت رؤاهم
العسكريه طبعا فشل
وايضا اللي صار انه
السيد احمد الشريف حقيقه طرد
حقا ان هو يذهب للمنفى فذهب الى بغواصه
المانيه الى الى الى اسطنبول
ورحب بك كثيرا
قالت الجهاد الاسلامي ولكن هذه الفتره
كانت
الحلفاء بداوا يغزوا فيه
تعداد الغزو
تركيا
[موسيقى]
الفتاه لم يعجبهم كثيرا هذه الشخصيه
الكاريزميه القويه فاضطر هو بهدوء انه
يهاجر وذهب للحجاز
وعاش في الحجاز حتى وفاته في عام 33 اعتقد
ودفن في الحجاز الملك ادريس محمد ادريس
السنوسي رحمه الله عليه
بعد وفاته في مصر طلب انه يتم في الحجاز
ايضا
عبد الرحمن كيف تداخل العالم الاسلامي
برغم الدوله الحديثه كل شيء لكن هناك
اشياء
متداخله
انا طبعا يعني لم اكمل الاجابه على سؤالك
اللي صار انه بعد الهزيمه العسكريه بعد
عشرين سنه من المقاومه
السيد احمد الشريف انتهى بالمنفى في
الحجاز وتوفى في الحجاز الامير محمد ادريس
السنوسي كان من فيه في القاهره
موجود في مصر
وكان نظر السيد ادريس السنوسي الافاوض
ويكون عندك حليف
وكان طبعا جزء مهم منها يعني كان اشكالي
بالتاكيد وكانت الجماعات في الغرب الليبي
في شخصيه كارزميه لعائله سيف النصر
هذول كانوا منقاده الجهاد ايضا وهم كانوا
سنوسيين المذهب
وفي الغرب الليبي كان القاده الجمهوريين
اللي حكينا عليهم واللي كتير منهم انتوا
في المنفى في مصر وفي
السعوديه وفي لبنان وفي سوريا وفي مصر وفي
تونس
فصار التفاوض
جاءت تاريخ اعطاء المجتمع الليبي فرصه
ذهبيه لم حد يتوقعها هزيمه الفاشيه
الايطاليه مع الالمان في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه في حروب العالمين وما تبعها في
غزو الحلفاء الى اوروبا
فبدا
بدات التفاوض في المنفى ودخل ليبيا على
الاستقلال
وكانوا الصراع بين الاستقلال والوحده هل
نحتاج نظام فدرالي والى نظام موحد
واتفقوا ووصلوا الى قناعه
انا اسميها التوافق التاريخي
اللي خلق الاستقلال الليبي حاجتين الحاجه
الاولى انه هو تحالف مع الحلفاء اللي هم
كانوا يضرب بعين التعاطف على على كيان
ليبي يكون حليفهم بس الشيء الاخر استغلال
النضال والجهاد اللي ضد الطليان والتضحيات
في عنا
رضوا بقياده
الامير محمد المهدي السنوسي اللي هو كان
علاقته قويه مع الحلفاء
واللي دخل مع الحلفاء في في مجموعه متطوع
سموا الجيش السنوسي دخل من مصر الى ليبيا
فبدا الصراع على الاستقلال وايضا طبيعه
الدوله هل هي تكون افدراليه ام موحده
واخيرا اتفقوا على الاستقلال
ولكن كدوله ملكيه فيدراليه دستوريه ليش
اختاروا انها تكون دوله ملكيه لان
شيئين
القياده اللي هو الاكثر بروزا واكثر تقبلا
حفيد الحركه تمثل الحركه السنوسيه وحركه
قاده الجهاد الليبي
وتاريخها خاصه قاده الاوائل
بالتالي فيه رصيد كبير في الشرق الليبي
والجنون الليبي للحركه وجزا حتى من الغرب
الليبي في الدواخل
وايضا الملك الامير في ذلك الفتره الامير
محمد اديش روسي اجتهدوا كان اجتهادا كان
في كثير من الحصافه طبعا كتير من
الجمهوريين الليبيين وحتى جيلنا احنا
والجيل اللي قبلنا انتقلوا هذه الاشياء
كيف التحالف مع الانجليز كيف تعطي قواعد
على شادي وانا اعتقد هذا نوع من القفص الى
حد كبير على على تلك المرحله ما كان متاح
وهو ان ليفا موحده بتحالف مع دوله غربيه
لان الجمهوريه طرابلسيه لم يكن لها حليف
دولي
وحطموها الطليان بسرعه بعد سنتين الملك
محمد الامير محمد ادريس السنوسي بويا
من القيادات الليبيه في الجنوب الليبي
طبعا هم سلوسيين سيف النصر وفي الغرب
الليبي القيادات
الحضريه
والبدوي والريفيه في الغرب الليبي توصلت
الى ان على مضض لا بد ان نقبل
ببيعه
واستخدموا شيء من التقاليد الاسلاميه
والعربيه والبيع بيعه الامير محمد
ادريس السنوسي اللي هو امير البلاد
هذا هذا التوافق اللي هو نبي برايي كان
توافق مهم وتاريخي سواء انتقدناهم لا
لانهم كثير ليبيا هناك جدل كبير عليه
وخاصه بعد 69
جدد هذا الجدل
ادى الى
نضال شعبي وتاجيج من اجل الاستقلال ليبيا
ضد التقسيم ليبيا الى ثلاث دول
فكانت في خطط تقسيم نعم كان في برنامج ما
بين الفرنسيين والطليان
[موسيقى]
والبريطانيين لحد كبير
كان بيقسم ليبيا ايطاليا تعود الى
الوصايه الايطاليه فزان تحت
الوصايه الفرنسيه وبركه تحت الوصايا
البريطانيه
الى حد كبير
فما حصل صار في اتحاد صار في اتحاد من
ناحيه القيادات وصار في تاجيل شعبي ضد
الشعب الليبي قطاعات نفسها وتظاهرت رسائل
وتلغرامات
وصعدت المساله طبعا انشاء الجامعه العربيه
تلك الفتره ساعدوا خاصه ان اول امين
للجامعه الدول العربيه وهو السيد
عبد الرحمن عزام
كان من ضمن انضم للمقاومه الليبيه والجهاد
الليبي وكان احد
مستشاريع جمهوريه طرابلسيه
وزوجته الاولى والثانيه الليبيات
شوف التداخل مره اخرى تشوف التدخل العربي
هذا في المنطقه يعني
في نفس السياق انا طبعا لازم اقول لك على
المساله هذه يعني من اصل ليبي جده من
مصراته
من اصل اسرته من اصل مغربي
من مراكش
[موسيقى]
واعتقد ان يعني الان صعب شويه لان الحدود
صارت مرسومه والدول صارت عندها اكثر
اوضوحا في في حدودها لكن حتى منتصف القرن
العشرين العالم العربي والاسلامي كان في
نوع من السيوله
باللغه الانجليزيه سيوله للتنقل
والزواج والاقامه
وبالتالي لا بد ننظر هذا بعين الاعتبار
هذا بدنا نحكي على على توافق التاريخ
انا براي هذا التوافق التاريخي اللي هو
غائب الان
القيارات الليبيه تكفر
وتمارس خطاب
الاغتيال المعنوي والشخصي لكن الذي خلق
الاستقلال الليبي هو هذا التوافق التاريخي
بين الكيانات الليبيه وبالتالي في طبعا
بمباركه ودعم القوه الغربيه بالذات
بريطانيا في البدايه والولايات المتحده
فيها بعد واستقلت ليبيا كملكيه دستوريه
فيدراليه لكن في عام 62
قرروا انه بحكم النفط والمصاريف وغيرها
موحده والغي النظام الفيدرالي
شو الفرق يعني هي كانت المملكه المتحده
الليبيه المملكه الليبيه المتحده
وش اللي حصل العام 62 خليها تتغير
شيئين طبعا احنا في عاملين العامل الاول
هو انه
النفط اكتشف في ليبيا في نهايه الخمسينيات
وفجاه ليبيا صارت انتقلت من افقر دول
العالم
اذا دوله غنيه وبعدين بسبعينيات صارت
في المنطقه
فاللي صار انه
اداره الاقتصاد الليبي اعتقد
تطلبت انها تكون فيه مركزيه للتخطيط
والنظام اللي كان فيه ثلاث حكومات عاصمتين
مجالس تشريعيه كانت بين خراطيه يعني رغم
ان الان الفيدراليين بعد 2011
يعطوا فيه صوره ورديه وحالمه على النظام
الفيدرالي طبعا الازم اكون منصف لهم لان
اعتقدوا ان التهميش اللي صار بعد القذافي
خاصه المنطقه الشرقيه مهم ولازم واحد يكون
يعني حساس وفاهم مشاعرهم انا اتفهم هذا
جيدا لكن الحقيقه النظام الفيدرالي النظام
المالكي نفسه النخبه وصلت الى قناعه انه
هو من ناحيه العمليه غير مجد وتكون نظام
ممتاز انا اتمنى لليبيين الان يعيدوا
اكتشافه نظام المحافظات
ولايات صارت تحاول فيها اكثر من عشر
محافظات وكان فيها نظام محلي
العبره في نهايه الامر اخويا عبد الرحمن
المساله مش في الاسامي هل من ناحيه
الفعليه
في يكون الحكم محلي وتمكين للناس انهم
يديروا اذا يعني شؤونهم الاقتصاديه
والاداريه والقضائيه والتعليميه بشكل
حقيقي والا لا لان بكل سهوله نقدر نعمل
الدستور الفلاني ونعمل
البرنامج الفلاني ونعمل الشركه الفلانيه
لكن في نهايه الامر كيف نطبق هذه الاشياء
التاريخ
الاجتماعي الليبي والصراع من اجل
الاستقلال كان معقد
رحمه من ربه من ربي ان الطليان يعني هزموا
في الحرب العالميه الثانيه وهدف فتح
الفرصه للقوى المعارضه والشعب الليبي انه
يعيد ترتيب ادواته كانت قيادات عبقريه
وملتزمه وكفئه اللي هي كانت تناضل من اجل
استقلال في المنفى
وخاصه في دمشق جمعيه الدفاع
البرقاء الطرابلس البرقاوي وكانوا من
ضمنهم شخصيه مميزه جدا
وزعيم بارز اسمه الاستاذ بشير السعداوي
اللي هو كان احد
مستشاريه الملك عبد العزيز رحمه الله عليه
في
لما نفي
كان تعلم تعليم العثماني وكان شخصيه بارزه
في المنطقه الغربيه وهو كون حزب اسمها حزب
المؤتمر طرابلسي فيما بعد فهذه
الليبي الحديثه تكونت من خلال هذه
الصراعات المحليه والاقليميه والصراعه من
اجل استقلال من الاستقلال وكانت مركبه
ومعقده ماشي القذافي هذا موضوع اخر لكن
خلينا نعرج على موضوع دموي والبشع في
المعتقلات اللي احنا
الرجال يعني احس ان فيه كم نقطه ودي ارجع
لها
برجع الى
القرن السادس عشر
ليبيا تحت الحكم العثماني كيف علاقتها
بالدوله العثمانيه
سؤال وجيه
كانت ولايه طرفيه
سمى ولايه طرابلس الغرب ما كانت تسمى
ليبيا كما ذكرت لك من يعني من حوالي ساعه
عبد الرحمن كان اسم ليبيا زي ما تونس كانت
يالاه تونس
والجزائر كانت دوله الدايات في الجزائر
الاسم ليبيا
هو اسم قديم في قبائل ليبو من فتره
الرومانيه قديمه جدا ولكن الرومان كان
يسمون ليبيا نسبه للقبائل الليبيه ليبيا
فالطليان وحده يعني احد الاشياء اللي
يحاولوا انهم
يبروا فيها غزو اللي بيقولوا احنا مش
جايين استعمار احنا نعود في البحر المتوسط
كانت بحيره رومانيه
وليبيا كان جزء من الامبراطوريه الرومانيه
ونحن ورثه الامبراطوريه الرومانيه شوف
العجب والكذب هكذا تبريرهم للاستعمار
جزء من الخطاب الرسمي يقول احنا عدنا الى
ليبيا هذه جزء منا لينا كما ان البحر
المتوسط كان بحيره رومانيه ونحن ونحن
الفاشون الجدد
امين المستعمر الطليان الطليان في 2011
وبعد خاصه الفاشين يقولون احنا ورثه
المطريه الرومانيه
فلو سالت اي عربي
مثلا في القرن السابع عشر
عن ليبيا ما بيعرف شيء اسمه ليبيا
يقول لك طرابلس حتى الان
ممكن ما يعرف الان الليبين طبعا العربيه
الاسم
كان كان غائب تماما
من الشعب اللي بكثير لان العائلات عندكم
كمان الجزيره العربيه تلقى جزء من شمال
اليمن وجنوب اليمن تلقاهم هنا وهناك
الكويت والسعوديه يعني شمر تلقاها في في
العراق وفي السعوديه وفي سوريا مثلا نفس
العمليه في
تونس خاصه الجنوب التونسي بدليل انه رقيبه
زي ما حكيت لك انه جده هو الاكبر كان كان
من مدينه نصرات
ولهذا كانت لي بيقول لك طرابلس فكانت هي
ولايه غرب طرابلس الغربس الغرب تمييز عن
بناء طرابلس الشام كان في طرابلسين وليست
طرابلس يعني حتى المشاهدين يفهموا هذا هو
اسم قديم روماني قديم كانت فيه ثلاث دول
مدن بيزنطيه رومانيه اللي هي سبرايتا
ماغنس
وطرابلس المدن الثلاث اللي هو تغيرت
باللغه العربيه وصارت طرابلس او طرابلس
فكان في طرابلس
الغرب الولايه رابس الغرب اللي هي من
منتصف القرن السادس عشر حتى عام 1900 كانت
في فتره في استقلاليه دوله قرماليه حكمت
هي ضابط عثماني استقلت كما صار في ولايه
عثمانيه
ولكن
خوف الدوله العثمانيه من مجيء واستغلت حرب
اهليه ما بين
اعضاء الاسره بعدت بالجيش العثماني
خوفا من سقوط طرابلس كما سقطت الجزائر
وتونس
فترابط الغرب يا اخي عبد الرحمن هي اخر
ولايه عثمانيه في شمال افريقيا
ولهذا لكن في شرق الليبي احيانا متصرفين
بنغازي كانت متصرفيه مستقله تتبع ذل
العثمانيه ولكن بشكل عام
لما تقول حتى في تركيا تقول
بنابش الاخوه الاتراكم يقول لهم انا
طرابلس غرب يبتسموا
[ضحك]
لان عارف ان الذاكره التاريخيه ورموزها
لها معنى معنى كبير
ليبيا ايضا حتى
الاجابه اكثر يعني اخر نقطه في الاجابه
على هذا السؤال
ليبيا
من ناحيه
التاثير العثماني طويل ولكن التاثير
العثماني كان دائما يتركز على المدن
الدواخل المدن طرابلس والخمس مصراته
الزاويه يعني
بنغازي
دارنا الدواخل كانت مستقله
مستقله بحيث انها تحكم نفسها بنفسها يعني
من ناحيه من ناحيه الاسميه تتبع الدوله
العثمانيه ولكن من الناحيه الفعليه كانت
مثلا
شفنا الحركه الثلاثيه كانت تحكم حكم ذاتي
مستقل ينافس الدوله العثمانيه في الدواخل
دواخل يعني المناطق الداخليه هذا اسم
المستخدم في شمال افريقيا وايضا في القرن
السادس عشر وحتى القرن بدايه القرن التاسع
عشر في فزان تكونت دوله اسسها شيء احد
الاشراف من مدينه فاس اسماء محمد بن ادريس
الفاسي
احنا نسميها دوله اولاد محمد محمد هو لفظ
في عندنا في شمال افريقيا بدل ما نقول
احيانا نقول محمد واحمد
لكن ايضا عندنا باللهجه المغاربيه نقول
محمد في الصعيد اكتشفت انه حتى الاخوان
الصعايد المصريين يقولوا محمد ايضا فيسموا
محمد واحمد
وايضا محمد لما يدلعوا الليبيين محمد عبد
الرحمن وهذه
يقول محمد يسموه حميده ولهذا جدي كان عمي
اجداد اثنين عندهم واحد محمد الكبير محمد
الصغير فالصغير اسمه حميده الصغير
[موسيقى]
الدوله العثمانيه الان في 86
بدا الاستعمار
الايطالي لليبيا 1911
الغزو بس انت فصلته الى انه قسمت الايطالي
الى قسمين انه استعمار اقتصادي
ايديولوجي بدل من 86 الى 1911
وفي غزو العسكري من 1911 الى لا هو هو
اللي صار يا عبد الرحمن ان الطليان بدا
لما بداوا في التفكير كانوا عيونهم يبقوا
ياخدوا تونس يستعمروا تونس الفرنسيين
اخذوهم منهم في 1881
اوك وفي جاليه ايطاليه كبيره
في في
تونس حتى الستينيات
ولكن لما الفرنسيين استعمرت تونس لحمايه
مسامرتهم الكبيره والمهمه الجزائر
ووجدوا تواضع من الاسره
الحسينيه اللي هم مبايات تونس
طليان بداوا في التفاوض مع الفرنسيين ومع
الالمان ومع مع الانجليز
وافقوا اغطت لهم ولايه طرابلس الغرب
في مقابل اعترافهم بحقوق الفرنسيه في
المغرب وايضا في تونس
بينما كانت تبغى تونس فلوت بتونس ورغبتهم
في تونس
وليبيا باي دافع
طبعا المشروع الاستعماري هو مشروع كان
توسعي لان يعتقدوا الدول الاوروبيه كانت
تعتقد انها عندها حق
نتوسع من ناحيه الاقتصاديه ومن ناحيه
الديموغرافيه وايضا اعتقدت ان بررتها بان
تبي مصادر للثروه مصادر الاستيطان اسواق
وررتها ان من حقها كدول متقدمه ومتمدنه
انها انها تستعمر الدول الضعيفه يسموها
يعني عبء الرجل الابيض قبل يقود
بردولوجيه الرومانيه نحن يعني احفاد
الامبراطوريه الرومانيه ففيه طبعا يعني
اعذار واديولوجيات سخيفه ومضحكه ولكن
هذه اشكاليه الاستعمار الاستعمار كان طبعا
احنا ما نعرفوش كعرب ان الاستعمار
والايديولوجيه الاستعماريه تجاه الشعوب
غير المستعمره هي كانت عنصريه ومتعمقه في
العلم في التعليم في الثقافه في المجتمعات
الاوروبيه وصارت حتى مثلا انا اذكر ان في
كتاب قراءه وطالبتي انه حتى العلماء بداوا
يفكر يقولوا والله انها في الطبيعه فيه
اشجار وفيه وفي حيوانات
تنقرض وبالتالي في شعوب من حقها تستمر
لانها عندها قدره على على القوه
والمناعه وكل شيء والشعوب التعبانه هذه
والمتخلفه وكذا تنقرض شيء طبيعي فصار نوع
من تطبيع
العنصريه
والاستعمار وايضا حتى الاباده
طيب
الحين احنا نقدر نتفق انه من 86 الى 1911
كان فيه
عبد الرحمن مركز على 86 ليش انت
طبعا انا
يعني كان في حضور اقتصادي الدخول
ايطالي على ليبيا من هالجانب وهي بدات عبد
الرحمن في الاعداد لما لما خسروا تونس
في كتابك تقول بالحرف ان الاستعمار
الايطالي بين عامي
1986 الى 1911 كان بدافع اقتصادي ايدولوجي
في شرق اوروبا في شرق افريقيا في اريتريا
اول مستعمر كانت اريتريا عبد الرحمن
اول مستعمره لهم
وبعدين المستعمر الثاني كانت ليبيا
قبل قبل طرابلس
قبل 19 نعم نعم وكان فيه اللي هو عن طريق
الاقراض ومصرف روما داروا اعملوا بنك روما
جاء باعطاء قروض
بشروط كثير ممتازه للناس والفكره مش هدف
البنك ما كانش حذف نجاح اقتصادي هو شراء
اراضي تغلغل في المجتمع خلق فئات يعني
مرتبطه اقتصاديا ونفسيا واجتماعيا
بالمشروع الاستعماري وبداوا يكونوا في
مدارس صحف او يبعثوا في رحاله للتمهيد لها
للغزو فهما بداوا بالتمهيد الاقتصادي اللي
حضرتك يعني
لكن
الطليان مروا بمشكله انهزموا مع من الحبشه
في
في في معركه اسمها معركه عدوى كان عندهم
طاعش ومغامر ومغرور
كالعه راسها من الاحباش وانهزموا والعند
الان مشروع الاستعماري في بدايه القرن
العشرين يبكوا على معركه عدوى ولا بد من
الانتقام من عدوى فشوف كيف الذاكره
التاريخيه الاستعماريه الاوروبيه واحنا
العرب لازم نهتم مش بس انه اللي صار في
بلداننا لابد ان ندرس تاريخ الاوروبي
والثقافه الاوروبيه وايضا المخاوف
والتحيزات وايضا الرموز وكيف يفسروا في
الاشياء هذه وبالتالي هذا كان له تبعات
فيما بعد على غزو الجزائر وغزو تونس وغزو
ليبيا وايضا
العربيه التي استعمرت بشكل مباشر طيب لما
تقول انه بدافع اقتصادي واضح ايدولوجي
كانت الايدولوجيه اللي كانوا
الاستعماريه تبرير
الاستعماريه تبريل التغلغل الاقتصادي
والديموغرافي في الجزائر وفي ليبيا في
خلاف عن بقيه المناطق الاخرى وهي ان كان
ينظر على الجزائر وليبيا على اساس ان هي
جزء من ايطاليا وجزء من فرنسا وكان
كان فيه خطه
محدده لارسال مستوطنين
الفرنسيين كان عندهم حوالي مليون مستوطن
الاقدام سوداء في الجزائر وفي ليبيا كانوا
بدل ما يعطوا اراضي للفلاحين
الطليان خاصه في الجنوب الايطالي في صقليه
سيسيليا
جاءوا بحل اخر
خططوا لتوطين نصف مليون
فلاح ايطالي في ليبيا
وشوف كيف تبريرهم يا عبد الرحمن قالوا
قالوا الاتي انا قرات طبعا
الادبيات الاستعماريه والصحف والاعلانات
والكتب عن هذا الموضوع قال والله ان
المهاجرين في في امريكا وفي امريكا
اللاتينيه يعني
تصرف معاهم ويهانوا احنا نبغى ايضا حاجه
اخرى مستعمره جزء منه وبالتالي ان الموطن
فيها مواطنين ويكونوا رايدين
ومستانسين وما عندهم اي مشكله المشكله زي
ما صار في فلسطين الان ان في ناس
في فلسطينيين وفي جزائريين المسلمين وعرب
وفيه وامازيق وفيه ليبيين مسلمين وعرب
فبدا هذا على طبيعه الصراع الايديولوجي
وانا اقول لك ايضا التبريرات الاكاديميه
اللي احنا ما نقرا على العرب نقرا الا ما
كتب عنا وما ترجم عنا لكن كنا نقرب
الايطالي والفرنسي ولا بالانجليزي وخاصه
اللغه الانجليزيه الان اللغه المهيمنه ان
المصادر موجوده لما تقرا المصادر الاولويه
وانا دائما كنت تعمل في شيء يا عبد الرحمن
من بدايات تكوين الاكاديمي اني كنت لا
ادرس هذه القضايا من جانب المصادر
الثانويه
كنت ادرس الارشيف كمؤرخ
اعمل المقابلات الشفهيه وايضا امارس العمل
الميداني اني اروح
بكاء بالاله التصوير وبجائزه التسجيل
وهذا اللي عملته وهذا افادني لان اعتقد ان
حتى الارشيف لازم مهم الارشيف لا لا اقول
الارشيف مش مهم لكن الارشيف هو كتب بلغه
المهيمن المستعمر وخياراته ماذا
يعني تذكر وماذا تنسى ما هو المسكوت عنا
وما هو المتاح وما هو مخفي ولهذا انا ازعم
ليس في الحاله الليبيه فحسب ان التاريخ
كثير من تاريخ العربي خاصه تاريخ المجتمع
مسكوت عنا ومخفي ولم يكتب بعد هذه فرصه
للاجيال الجايه اللي تكون من الاعداد
منهجي واعداد
لغوي وعداد
تفكير ناقد انه يعيد اثاره اسئله جديده
على مواضيع نعتقد انها محسوبه وهي مش
محسوبه يا عبد الرحمن 1911
جاء الاستعمار
العسكري الايطالي
كنت في كتابك قلت ادل الاستعمار الايطالي
لا زلزل عنيفه
للمجتمع الليبي يعرف يعني ما طبيعه هاي
الزلزله
العنف
يعني جيش حديث
مدرعات بنادق حديثه
مدافع
اوارج تضرب بعنف
ناطق مثال مثلا معركه شارع الشط يعني من
البدايه
يعني خارج ضواحي ترابلس
فوجئ الطليان
وهذا طبعا كان
مصالح الليبيين انه
اعتقدوا ان الدعايه الايطاليه كانت بتقول
ان الليبين كانوا متخلفين
ومضطهدين
وبؤساء لان الحكم العثماني كان سيء
واحنا جينا باش ننقدهم ونطورهم ونمدنهم
فلما بدا الغزو في بدايه اكتوبر كيف تقبل
الليبيون هذا الكلام
هذه الدعايه هذه الدعايه طبعا
الغالبيه العظمى ضحكوا عن المساله في
البدايه لكن لكن خليني اكون اكثر انصافا
وهذا الكلام طبعا
الليبين طبعا دائما يهربوا منها في فئه
تواضعت في فئه تواطات يا عبد الرحمن متى
نعطيك مثال واحد من يعني عميد يعني
مدينه طرابلس كان يحلم انه يصير كيف
الباين تاع تونس انه
الفرنسيين يعمدوه كحاكم ويحكم من خلالهم
او من خلال التوافق معه
فهو ساعد في عمليه الغزو في طبعا اسر
ليبيه كانت عندها صراعات مع الدوله
العثمانيه
وخلافات واعتقدوا انهم يعني قوموا خصومهم
في مصراتها في الجبل
ضدهم هم وبالتالي لم يعتقدوا انه هو تواضع
يعتقدوا ان احنا ناخذ حقنا وبالتالي فيه
مثلا اسر مزعمات والله احنا جبنا بطليان
نعم من اجل هذا
المساعدات والتواتر فتح الحصون مساعده
استخباراتيه على الحصول وعسكريه احيانا
جمع حتى السلاح
ومستشارين مستشارين
الغزو الايطالي لكن
الشيء اللي هو طبعا لم يتوقع الجيش
الايطالي 1911 في نهايه 1911 ان تكون فيه
مقاومه او منظمه باسلحه بدائيه ولكن مجتمع
منظم لم يكن مؤدلج
كان متماسك وكانوا يناظر من اجل الاسلام
والوطن هذه كانت الفكره الاساسيه فيه
واعتقد ان مثلا في شارع الشط عشان صارت
مذبحه شو اللي حصل جيش الايطالي تقدم بعد
ما ضرب دكل المدن الخمس وترابلس والزاويه
بنغازي ودارنا وكذا واحتل في البدايه تقدم
لان طبعا القوه التكنولوجيه والعسكريه
كانت شيء لا يعني لا يتصور خاصه بالنسبه
تقدموا والمجاهدين
عملهم كمين
منطقه شعب وقتلوا مجموعه من الضباط
والجنود
انتقم الجيش الايطالي
بارتكاب مجزره ادت الى وفاه ما بين ثلاثه
الاربعه الاف ما بينهم ما بينهم اطفال
ونساء وغيرها معروفه انها مذبحه شارع الشط
فكانت فكانت شرسه خليني اعطيك قصه شويه
لطيفه عشان نخفف على المشاهدين
كانت في اسلحه مثلا لا تنسى
الناس اللي بيفتك الفتره او طرابلس
في تلك الفتره وفزان كانوا الحكم لا كان
الناس كانت تحمل السلاح لان عشان قطعانهم
واملاكهم وارزاقهم ومزارعهم لان الدوله
المركزيه العثمانيه كانت محدوده حتى مساله
الخطف والسرقه والكلام مهم بالنسبه لهم
فالسلاح
والتدرب على السلاح كان مهم
وايضا الدوله الحركه والطريق السنوسيه
لعبه دور حافل في التعداد على الامد
البعيد يعني عبقريه الحركه السنوسيه
انها لان مؤسسها كان جزائري عالم جزائري
ولم يستطيع العوده الى بلده
ولهذا كان فكره انه لن نبدا بالسلاح
باعداد الانسان تعليم
التجاره
والتركيز على على الاكتفاء الذاتي
غير عادي يعني هو واتباعه والقاده اللي
فيما بعدها
اخذت يعني بداوا في منتصف القرن التاسع
عشر يعني خلال خمسين سنه وهم يبنوا في
مجتمع لما جاء الطليان
واجهوا مجتمع متماسك رغم انه فقير ويمكن
حافي واكله تمر ولبن وشويه حاجات بسيطه
يعني
ولكن متماسك وعنده معرفه
وعي باستقلاليتها والخطر
الذي جاء في البلدان المجاوره الجزائر
تونس
وبالتالي ما كانوش يعني خارج خارج
المنطقه ككل وما يجري فيها من ناحيه من
ناحيه هذه وكتاباتهم
ومراسلاتهم تشير الى كان في وعي عميق
باداهم هل كانوا يعتقدون ان الفرنسيين
اللي بيهاجمونهم ولا كانوا على الحركه
الفرنسيه
لما جاءت الفرنسيين في التشاد وبداوا في
التوغل فالدافعوا عن زواياهم زوايا اللي
زي ما عشان
المشاهدين والمستمعين عندنا في الجزيره
العربيه وفي المشرق الزاويه ولفظ مغاربي
يعني يعني مسجد احنا نقول له زاويه
اللي هو بالنسبه للثلثيه كان مسجد مدرسه
فندق
مجلس قضائي
ويتبرع الاهالي والناس
بالارض وبالعمل وواقف من اجل هذه
الزاويه والحركه السنوسيه كانت توفر
العلماء والائمه والمدرسين والمدربين لما
بدا المدربين حتى على السلاح والحرف
يعني
مكتبه المعهد الاعلى في الجربوب كانت فيها
الاف الكتب بالطليان دمروها فيما بعد فهنا
تاتي شيء معظم المؤرخين يقفزوا عليه وهو
دائما يركزون على الجهاد انا برايي النجاح
الاكبر للحركه السلوكيه والجمهوريه
الرابطيه
والصفوف خاصه الصف الفوقي في صفوف
التحالفات الفلاحيه القبليه
ميزتها انها كونت من خلال ثراتها ومن خلال
مؤسساتها ادوات لتنظيم نفسها
ليس فقط في القرن التاسع عشر ولكن حتى في
مواجهه هذا الغول الكبير الذي جاء
باساطيله ومدافعه ودباباته وطائرات لاول
مره بدائيه
ولهذا هذا التماسك يفسر الاستمراريه وانا
ازعم ايضا نجاح الطريقه السنوسيه
ليس في الجهاد والقتال
في تاسيس
[موسيقى]
وتنوير المجتمع المحلي
وتوحيده يا عبد الرحمن توحيده توحيده
الخطب
والمواعظ لا توحيدها من خلال رؤيا جديده
لكيفيه بناء المؤسسات كيف ان التعليم هو
يوحد مفتوح على كل الفئات
مبني على الكفاءه
وبالتالي خارت الحركه السنوسيه شيء عجيب
اللي اكتشفته
منهم من اصل اليمني من اصل الغرب ليبيا
جنوب ليبيا من تشاد من الحجاز من تونس من
الجزائر ومن المغرب
وقاره الاخوان
وقاده الادوار اللي هي
الجماعات العسكريه المقاتله لتضرب
كروه فر
وكانوا منهم خليط عجيب جدا ويوحدهم اللي
هو الاسلام السنوسي السني الاصلاحي الجديد
الطليان اعتقدوا هل كان للدوله العثمانيه
دور في في المدد ولا في الجيش هذا سؤال
مهم في البدايه طبعا شعروا السلطان
العثماني ووزراءها ونخبه شعروا بالخجل
وايضا شعروا بالذنب
لان الحمل الحاميه الحاميات العثمانيه في
ليبيا كان حوالي 5000
وهناك بعض اتهامات ان بعض وزراء تواضع مع
ايطاليا في انه يخففوا من
بحجه مساعده انتفاضه في اليمن
[موسيقى]
واللي صار ايضا انه
اعطوا الاستقلال للشعب الليبي لطرابلس
الناس المسلمين في طرابلس ولكن كانت اوكي
انتم من المستقلين جاوكم ربنا يوفقكم لكن
انتما اعطيناكم الاستقلال يعني فكانت هي
طبعا اضعف الايمان ولكن مش اضعف الايمان
يعني كانت نوع من يعني الوجه طب والسلاح
بيجي من مصر هل كان من من مصر ولا كان من
خلال الدوله العثمانيه الدوله العثمانيه
يا بعد عن طريق جمعيه يعني تشكيلات مخصوصه
وهذه من جمعيه سريه
وايضا اخذ بعض ابناء الوجهاء والاعيان
وتدريبهم خاصه مهم في البدايه مصطفى كمال
كان في الجبهه الشرقيه في درنه
وفي
النظام ضد ضد الطليان وبعد وبعد فيما بعد
بعد دخول
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه بعد تردد في جانب
المانيا بالحرب العالميه الاولى
بعثوا بمساعدات اكبر ولكن للتاريخ
وللانصاف يا عبد الرحمن
هناك
جنود وضباط اتراك عثمانيين طبعا في ناس
بالعالم العربي زي يعني
ضباط عراقيين ضباط مصريين ضباط سوريين
يمنيين بعض منهم قرروا
الانضمام للمقاومه الليبيه والمجاهدين
الليبيين وفي مهمه اللي ماتوا في ليبيا
في هذه الفتره فهي الفتره الحقيقه دمويه
ومرعبه ولكن فيها جوانب كثير مشرقه
وانسانيه
وايضا مجهوله للاسف الشديد
لاننا سؤال اصلي في الكتاب الاول لماذا
واجه المجتمع في ليبيا العثمانيه
بقوه متعدده
وليش التعدد الفعل للاستعمار الايطالي كان
يعني متنوع ومتعدد
وما هي
التبعات والعواقب المباشره وغير المباشره
الاستعمار الايطالي بعد بين 1911 الى
لما هزم هزم الحلفاء في الحلفاء النازيين
ولا الالمان والفاشين الايطاليين هذه
هذه الفتره
شحدت فاجعل
وجد الناس الراي العام ان دوله شرسه وقويه
بشات تقول هذا البلد لي وانا اجري احضركم
بالحديد والنار جماعه جمعيه الدفاع
الطرابلس البرقاوي عندهم كتاب حلو جدا
وجميل وعبقري
التمدن بالحديد والنهر التمدين بالحديد
والنار
الفضائع الحمر السود وهو وهو كتاب صغير
ولكن يوثق فضائح الفاشيه الايطاليه لجانب
عربي اسلامي
وهذا طبعا فيما بعد صار مهم لما يعني بدات
في الكتاب الثالث اللي هو بعد الدوله
والاستعمار الاصوات المهمهشه اللي هو
الكتاب الثالث اللي هو
الابال الجماعيه في ليبيا شر
تاريخ استعمار مخفي طيب بالنسبه للاقاليم
الثلاثه هل اختلفت المقاومه بين الاقاليم
الثلاثه الموجوده في ليبيا نعم
المنطقه الغربيه
اللي هي اكثر كثافه واكثر استقرارا
قاومت حتى
1915 والحقيقه في 1915 خلينا نتوقف شويه
عبد الرحمن لان صارت فيه معركه مهمه جدا
معركه القردابيه اتحدت القوى القوات تحت
رايه الحركه السلوكيه من الشرق سيستفيد
الدين السنوسي من الغرب
المجاهده رمضان السويحلي
والقاده الغرب الليبي
ومن الجنوب القائد البارز الكاريزماتي
احمد سيف النصر
وانقطت هذه كان القوات الغرب الليبي يفرض
انها تكون باندا باندا يعني تشتغل تابعه
القوات الايطاليه ولا تنقلبت عليها
انقلبت عليها
واتحدت القوات من الاقاليم الثلاثه وهزمت
الجيش الايطالي وانهت
يعني
الحياه المهنيه العسكريه
للجنرال يعني
واسر وقتل العديد من الضباط والجنود
والطليان
واستطاع المجاهدين ان يستولوا على الاف
المدافع والبنادق
واكياس التموين والارزاق وغيرها وكانت
معركه ممتازه منها
ادى الى الطليان بداوا يتفاوضوا خاصه
اعطاء استقلال محدود الحكم الذاتي للحركه
السنوسيه للاماره السنوسيه
واعترفوا الطرابلسيه في البدايه 1918
واعطوا استقلاليه للجنوب الليبي تحت السيد
احمد سيف الناصر وعبد الجليل سيف الناصر
فهذه المعركه مهمه
الوجود الايطالي كان في الدول المدن
الساحليه في بنغازي في درنه في سوسه في
الخمس في
طرابلس والزاويه بس
وهذا نتيجه طبعا للهزيمه الكبيره في معركه
القردابيه فيما بعد طبعا جاء الفاسيين
وقرروا انه لا حكم ذاتي لا تهاون مع
الكائنات الليبيه العربيه والمسلمه وبداوا
بداوا في عمليه يسموها ريكون كويستا اعاده
الغزو الايطالي
واستمرت الغاز يعني في المنطقه الغربيه
نجحوا في هزيمه المقاومه نقولوا
اضطر جل
السكان القيادات والقبائل والزعامات
للهجره
يامل تونس يعمل جنوب ليبيا في فزان يا اما
نتشاد يا اما مصر
وانا اسرتي طبعا جد جد اثنين واحد من
مختفى
اعتقدوا اهلنا اهلنا انه هو مات
واكتشفوا انه هو في قبيله ليبيه اسمها
المغاربه
لان كان معلم قران وشريف
ورجع لهم بعد عشر سنوات واكتشفوا انه
لازال حي جدي الاخر والد والدتي
اضطر للهجره لان كانوا يبغوا شكوا الحكم
عليه بالاعدام وعاش في المنفى في في شمال
تشاد في مدينه اسمها فايا فالرجو اسم
فرنسي
هذا الاسم المعروف العربي فيها
يعني المهم من هذه التفاصيل الاتي
الطليان نجحوا
في النهايه بعد عشرين سنه من حرب دمويه
وعنيفه وشرسه
في قتل منافي وتهجير كل الفئات المقاومه
او المجاهده لمشروع طب بالنسبه للمعتقالات
اللي انت قلتها كانت في نفس هذه الفتره
ولا نعم لكن صحيح اللي صار انه السياسه
المعتقلات هي جزء من السياسه العنيفه نحن
لن نرضى الا باستسلام كامل
وقبلنا نتكلموا عن عن مساله المعتقالات
خليني اضيف بس معلومه مهمه
انا قلت انها كان الشعب الليبي جاء يعني
واجه يعني
غزوه شرسه
ولكن برغم القتل ورغم المنافي
والاله الحديثه للجيش الايطالي
الاستعمار الايطاليا بحزم بتقدير المتواضع
شحد النفوس وعرف الليبيين من هم
ولهذا لا يحكوا لي على ازمه كلام
الليبيين زي ما قالت والدتي معروفين لكن
في ازمه سياسيه في فشل نخبه صحيح في فساد
صحيح لكن ما تحكيش على المواطن العادي
وتقول له انت من انت زي ما قالت والدتي
قالت انا علي يعني باللهجه السعوديه انا
بليبيه وانا مسلمه وعربيه يعني
نعود الان الى المعتقدات
الطليان
ضربوا بيد حديد ولكن للاسف الشديد لابد ان
اللي يبين يعترفوا انه فئات استطاعوا ان
يتغلغلوا
فئات متواضعه بدليل ان الجيش الايطالي في
نهايه العشريني
العسكري
يقول لك الحبش
ايضا مصور لانه من مدينه ميناء مصوره لكن
هم الطليان يقولوا لهم عسكري في الادبيات
الايطاليه سموهم العسكري يقول لك العسكري
وهو اسم عربي لكن صار جزء من اللغه
اللغات الاوروبيه يقول لك عسكري في في شرق
افريقيا وفي شمال وخاصه في ليبيا يقول لك
باللغه الانجليزيه والايطاليه تكتب عسكري
اللي صار انه
براي هذا هذا جدار الهويه احنا يعني احنا
قومنا من اجل ديننا وطنا وهويتنا لان
الاستعمار الايطالي لم يعطينا اي فرص اخرى
وحلقه مهمه بجانب المذابح العسكريه
الكبيره كانت صيانه واحد من الجرارات
الدمويين يسموه سفاح ليبيا
يعني هذا شو عمل يا عبد الرحمن
لان الامدادات كان تاتي من مصر متطوعين
ناس عربوا مسلمين يعني في المنفى يبعثوا
في الارزاق يبعثوا في السلاح ولكن لان
طبعا الناس كانت في حاله حرب ما قدرت
وتزرع وتعمل كذا
فترات لاحظ
لما ياتي الحصاد في الاول كان يبطل الجهاد
ويروحوا ويزرعوا
وهذا شيء طبيعي يعني ان ان في الفتره هذه
ان عشان حياتهم اليوميه يعني لازم ياخذوا
انهم قمحوا شعير
ولكن الفتره الاخيره ما قدروا فكان
مساعدات والتموين من مصر اللي صار انه
كريس يعني قرر انه يعمل
يعني حاجز
شائك 300 كيلو متر
بين ليبيا ومصر
وبعدين
يا سيدي العزيز
قام هو وثلاثه معه
بعمليه لم تسبقها اي شيء حتى في الجزائر
اللي هي فكره المعتقالات
فكره جنونيه هي الحقيقه جنونيه لكن لها
ليها قالوا انه والله ان عمر المختار
والمجاهدين اللي هم 5000 بين 4000 5000
ولكن ايضا عندهم عندهم زي ما تقول
ميه سمك في بحيره
يعني زي ما تقول النظريات يعني مضاده
للثورات والانتفاضات
فقرروا انهم
يهجروا
كل السكان المدنيين من شرق ليبيا
اللي هم مرتبطين بارتباط عضوي ومؤسساتي
وايديولوجي وتعليمي مع المقاومه والجهات
الكرزميه اللي هي الشيخ الشهداء عمر
المختار كان صلب كان محترم كان قوي
العزيمه وكان متواضع وبسيط
وكان معه طبعا مجموعه من الكوماندرز اللي
معاه رجال المقاومه المجاهدين فقرروا انه
جاءوا بخطه جنونيه
وشريره
يهجر كل سكان المدنيين حتى
يخنقوا المقاومه من ناحيه المتطوعين من
ناحيه الاخبار من ناحيه الاستخبارات من
ناحيه الدعم من ناحيه الاختفاء
ووجدت انها تقريبا رقم ما بين 100 الف الى
110 الف بني ادم
حجروهم من منطقه الغنيه والجميله
والزراعيه
جبل الاخضر
يا اما عن طريق بواخر ولا عن طريق المشي
ومعهم نص مليون حيوان من قطعانهم قبل وغنم
ماعز وخيل
وحطوهم في 16 معتقل
اسواهم خمس معتقلات اللي هي معتقل سريه
السلوك
المقرون
البريجا
خاصه اقارب المجاهدين وعمر المختار والناس
اللي كانوا منا
1929 هجروهم ماتوا ناس طبعا في الطريق
خاصه الاطفال وكبار السن
بعد 29
استمر الاعتقال واستطاعوا بعد الحاجز
الشاعك
وبالتهجير والخطه النبويه الشريره هذه
انهم
يخنقوا المقاومه وبدا
المقاومين يعني يسقط واحد حتى يعني قبض
على الشيخ الشهداء
وحوكم
واستشهد لكن المهم القصه اللي اختفت يا
عبد الرحمن وهذا مهم جدا انا سعيد انك
سالني سؤال هذا
كثير من الليبين لا يعرفوا على المعتقلات
العرب ما يفهموا الا عمر المختار وفيلم
عمر المختار
والطليان والحلفاء غطوا
وتستروا
على ارشيف المعتقلات
هذا الكلام لما اكتشف يعني بالبدايه ولكن
انا بدات رحله اباحيه سنه 2000
فرحت قلت انا الموضوع هذا
كالاتي كنت انا المعتقل هذا الموضوع خطير
من كتب عنه بين الليبين مؤرخ واحد بس كتب
رساله ماجستير مشكور دار اللي عليه
وخلالنا حاجه كيف
اول حاجه طبعا من خلال دراستي تروح
الدكتوراه عرفت انه في معتقلات
والدتي لما كنت صغير انا وخواتي
يعني
انقولوا لها طبعا ثقافتها شويه عاشت في
المنفى ولدت في المنفى وثقافتها لما نرد
والدتي كان بقيه ثقافه الدواخل
يا تقول لك بيت شعر
انتم شعر انتم في الجزيره تقولون الشعر شو
سموه الشعر
الفظيع الشعر
احنا نقول الشعبي نقول الشعر الشعبي احنا
هو نفس الشيء
لكن هو متغلغل في الثقافه الحياه اليوميه
تقريبا التعبير بين الناس كانت والدتي لما
نكلموها على شيء
مثل شعبي
وهذه ثقافتها واحنا بعدين نقعد نخمن
خاصه فكانت
مرضى انا مريض يقول لهم ما ابي مرض غير
دار العقيله وحبس القبيله وبعد الجبال من
بلاد الوسيله
طبعا فيما بعد اساسه ابتدائي
قرانا قصيده لشاعر وطني كبير اسمه احمد
رفيق المهدوي
اسمها غيث الصغير جاء المعتقل وكتب على
غيث صغير وكان فاحنا المدرس خلانا نقراها
وبعدين عملناها مسرحيه في الصف السادس
الابتدائي
لما قعدت ابحث في روحت الدكتوراه شنو
القضيه هذه في حاجه يعني هذا موضوع يعني
ممكن مجرد قصه طرفه او يعني شيء
طريف والا فيه شيء بشع واوسع وعميق اكتشفت
يا عبد الرحمن ان الموضوع
نجح الطليان في ان يردموا ويخفوا هذه
الجريمه
اكتشفت انها كانت 110 الف بني ادم
من الشرق ايوه وبعدين
قلت انا لازم هذا الموضوع خطير انا كان
عندي استاذ
هو زي زي ما تقول شيخي باللغه الاكاديميه
وليس اللغه القديمه
استاذ عربي امريكي العرب ما تعرف لا تعرف
ان الكثير لكن كان عبقري وكان صلب اسمه
رفعت عليه ابو الحاج سلطان فلسطيني امريكي
فمره احكي انا وياه في 1999 اذكر هذا
تحديدا
يا رفعه انا الان ابغى ابدا في البحث
والتحقيق في هذا الموضوع لاني ما لقيت شيء
عليه يملا العين لا بالعربي ولا
بالانجليزي
رغم اني انا من المتخصصين في المرحله
الاستعماريه
قال لي ضحك قال لي علي حياخذ منك
عشر سنين
انا صحيح ناخذ في العاده مانيش البحث اقعد
اربعه خمس سنين في الكتاب صحيح بس يطيب
ويستوي ويكون تمام ويكون جاهز لكن عشر
سنين هذا كتير انا ابغى اشرب قهوه او
ادردش مع اصحابي واخواني ابغى يعني اتفسح
ابغى اشوف افلام اسرع موسيقى يعني مش
معقول الواحد بقول ليل نهار وهو بس في
الدرس والخدمه يعني
الدراسه قال لي هذا موضوع معقد وانت لازم
تكون انك صبر ما تستعجلش عليه والحقيقه
الرسول صلى الله عليه الحق يا عبد الرحمن
بدات كالاتي بدات
باستراتيجيه اللي هي ثلاث محاور
اولا قلت خلني اروح اشوف طليان على
الموضوع
طبعا
1986 كيف كنت انا كيف بادي في الدكتوراه
سالت على الملفات تردد شوي وبعدين طردوني
قالوا لي هذا الموضوع
ما عندنا اعطينا اي شيء لانك انت من اصل
الليبي
والليبيين ما يخلونا ندرس الارشيف بتاعهم
وبالتالي المعامله بالمتر
رحت سالت الدكتور الجراري في مركز الجهاد
صحيح
قال لي هذا كذب احمر
قال الطليانيه
واحنا بالعكس نعامله فيهم بكل انفتاح ومن
غير تعقيد
مكتوبه
رجعت مره اخرى واخيرا
اكتشفت الاجابه
في مؤرخ ايطالي محترم جدا
ومعادن للاستعمار اسمه انجلود البوكر
من قلائل اللي كتبوا هم اثنين طليان كتبوا
عنه في واحد اسمه
1969 قال اللي صار في المعتقالات هذه
اباده ولازم
وفي مقال صغير وجامعه
وبعدين قلت له انا راني عندي مشكله انا
ابغى الملفات من غير ملفات كيف استطيع
احقق ما اقدر مثلا اتفلسف من عندي واخلق
تواريخ زي ما حدا ما يجوز
قال لي لا تضيع وقتك معاهم هدولا كانوا
المشرفين معظمهم كانوا فاشيين سابقين
وانا قضيت اربعين سنه في هذا الموضوع
واكتشفت انه يا اما عبثوا بالملفات اما
ازاحوها من الارشيف
بعدين قلت انا سالت سؤال منطقي يعني
لو انك في محلي عشان تعمل
منك يا علي روح الى شرق ليبيا ودور
الاحياء اللي كان عمرهم بين خمس سنوات
وعشر سنوات ما بين 29 واربعه طبعا
خلاص يعني عمر ما لكن قال لي هذول كانوا
اطفال لو انهم وافقوا انه يحكوا معك لو
اني انا منك اروح هناك واقدم عم وقت
فبدات يا عبد الرحمن من 2000 سنه 2000
لغايه 2010
عن طريق اصدقائي عن طريق معارفي في الشرق
الليبي وايضا ساعدني انه جدتي
هي من شرق ليبيا
هي من عائله بومريز اللي هي من كبار
عائلات قبيله الزويه والكفره
فبدات
ولما قابلتهم في الاول كانوا شكاكين قالوا
لي انت من من ابوك من اهلك ومن جدك ومن
امك وانت من ولما في بعضهم يعرفوني انام
الاشراف كذا وعرفوا اني انا اعرف تاريخهم
وعائلاتهم فبداوا يرتاحوا
يعني وافقوا انهم يحكوا
من الحديث عن الموضوع والله هو الموضوع
طبعا موضوع خطير لسببي
طبعا هم عندهم خوف تاريخي اللي حصل اهلا
في عائلات قطعه كل كامله نخبه الاستقلال
يوم الملك ادريس
والقاده اللي هم قادو الاستقلال الليبي
وهو انجاز كبير عمله يجتهدوا قالوا احنا
موضوع لمرحله الاستعماريه مش حنفتح
احنا مليئين
بالمنافي
والعنف
والرعب والمذابح وناس طلينه وناس تعاونت
وناس تواضعت هذا
ابواب لا نستطيع اني
واجتهد وانا لا اقول ان اجتهادهم كان سيء
انا اعتقد اجتهاد ليه ليه معايره وليه
حساباته
اريد ظروفهم لكن ادى الى ان هذه المواضيع
تصبح يعني
فارتاحوا لك
فهم طبعا قالوا لي وبعدين
القذافي طبعا جاء وهو بعنف في 69
انتم معدتكم وما حدش معبركم ولا حد كتب
عنكم صار ليل نهار ويصرخ في الاول فلو
صدقوه قالوا حد احنا عندنا حقنا احنا لم
نكتب تاريخنا وهذولا جو قدوه علينا
وقتلونا واخذوا ارضنا
[موسيقى]
وعمل فينا فضائع بشعه
لكن بعدين طبعا نظام القذافي وانا قلتها
في الكتاب الاخير ان بدا يوظف الاستعمار
الايطالي والجهاد
لصالح
نظامها ولصالح شرعيتها فصار في توظيف
سياسي
ين يشكوا في المساله
هم داروا استجواب لي انا
عملت حاجه حقيقه كانت موفقه جدا قلت انهم
هم قاموا بالسجواب
ومساءلتي وانا رضيت بها لانه فتح باب ما
هي اخلاق وما هو الهدف من البحث العلمي
وكتير من الناس قالوا لي هذا احسن شيء لان
خلى فتح موضوع في العاده الاستاذ ياتي وهو
يعرف عند ادواتها والناس العاديين هذول
عباره ناس رافضه وعلى قد حالهم وكذا لا
بالعكس تعاملهم كانهم انهم اراده وانهم
معرفه وعندهم رؤى وعندهم
روح وعندهم فهم وعندهم وعي ولا تنظر بشكل
ابوي ولا استاذي عليهم وانا بدا بدا
فقعت من الفين وعشره وانا يعني اعمل في
المقابلات
وفيما بعد طبعا مركز الجهاد مشكور اعطوني
كل التسجيلات اللي عملوها
وفي ناس صاروا لانها سمعوا عني وثقوا فيا
قولي والله لازم يجي عندنا احنا عندنا
امنا جدتنا ولا عندنا خالنا ولا ان جدنا
هنا قعدت ذاكرته قويه لازم تحكي معه فصرت
يعني
بدات الماده تتطور يا عبد الرحمن وبدات
وفي الاخير قررت اني طبعا فكك بالحديث اني
شفت الارشيف الايطالي بالانجليزي ارشيف
الامريكي ارشيف الفرنسي في تونس والارشيف
المصري خاصه الانجليزي والماده عن الموضوع
فعملت زي ما تقول بحث في ثلاث قارات بثلاث
لغات
الشيء الاخر اللي هو عديت نفسي فيه قعدت
نقرا كل ما كتب على الاباده وعلى الفاشيه
باللغه الايطاليه والانجليزيه باش نعد
نفسي لاني عارف اني انا مش ابغى اكتب حاجه
لليبيين وللعرب بس ابغى قدم حاجه معرفه
للعالم كله الاخرين يعرفوا ان هذا العربيه
اسلاميه
لكن هذه الناحيه فاللي صار انه
اخيرا قررت اني اعمل الحلقه الاخيره
قلت انا ابغى اروح ازور المعتقات الخمسه
معتقالات الموت
واكتشف طبعا ليش انا قلت اروح ازورها كشفت
من
110 الاف
اللي طلعوا احياء سته يعني ممكن 30 الف
يعني تقريبا ما بين 60 الف وربما حتى اكثر
من هيك 70 الف ماتوا ماتوا لما سالتهم
ماتوا من الجوع والامراض الطليان الفاشين
لم يحطوهم في يعني في في افران غاز والله
ياخذوهم
اعطوهم شويه شعير
لان الشعير احنا عندنا مش عارف في الجزيره
تحبوها احنا في ليبيا بنحب الشعير كتير
اهلنا
صحيح كويس لكن الشعير بالنسبه لهم حتى في
اكلات فيعطفيهم الناس شويه شعير اسود
ولما يمرضوا ما يعطيهمش لدواء ولا علاج
فمعظم الناس ماتوا من الجوع
وماتوا من الامراض
وحيواناتهم والقطعان هم اللي جابوهم معاهم
نفقت
تقريبا نص مليون حيوان نفر يا عبد الرحمن
ايضا العلاقه العضويه ما بين البني ادم
والبيئه والحيوان هذول في ناس قالولي لما
قالوا لي احنا قبل الطليان كنا احنا ناس
نعمل انه نحرد ونزرع ونتاجر وعندنا
حيواناتنا وعندنا مواطنا وعندنا مواطننا
وعندنا كل شيء احنا ما نبغاهم يطعمونا
احنا احنا بالنا من نفسنا فوجد نفسها في
عائلات كامله خمسين ستين قطعت يعني ماتت
في
واللي يسجل واللي سجل بشكل انساني وعميق
معظم
الثقافه الليبيه وبالذات التخاف البدويه
يتخاف الشفاهيه
وثقافه تركز على الشعر لان الشفاعه
ايضا
تتماشى مع الشعر في وزن وفي موسيقى
والامثال الشعبيه حتى ايضا فيها وزن
موسيقى فهذه طريقه التعبير الثقافي
والحياه اليوميه والتواصل بين الناس
فاكتشفنا ان كثير منهم
رجال ونساء
قالوا قصائد وحفظت هذه القصائد من ضمنها
المعلقه اللي قلت لك عليها اللي هي صارت
هي زي
الشوكه في ظهر الفاشيين والمستعمرين اللي
هي قصيده الفقيه الفقيه رجب وحويش المنفي
العظيم عشر صفحات مابي مرض غير دعم
العقيله وحبس القبيله وبعد الجبال من بلاد
الوسيله يقول انا مش مريض يا عبد الرحمن
ولكني مريض اللي نشوفها حولي
وهذه القصيده طبعا هائله انا طبعا يعني في
الكتاب حطيتها في الخلف وترجمت او ترجمتها
صديق لي
شاعر ابليبي امريكي وفيها هيدا القصيده
اخرى في نفس الوقت فوجدت ان الشعر الشعبي
او الشعر النبطي كما تقولون انتم في
الجزيره العربيه هو مصدر مهم طبعا يحتاج
ان الواحد ينظره مش بشكل رومانسي ولا
يضخمه ولا شيء تنضرب بهدوء وقعدت سنتين
باش نفهم ادبيات ولغات وطريقه التعبير و
اللهجات داخل اللهجات
افهمها كويس
بعدها طبعا اخذت
التصوير
وكان معي سائق واصدقائي دبروني
وذهبت في رحله لمده اربع ايام من معتقل من
المضخات الخمسه الى الاخر
وجدت شيء طبعا مخجل ان الدوله الليبيه في
العهد الملكي والعهد القذافي
يعني استثمرت في بعض اماكن المعتقلات طرق
وشركات واراضي وغيره وغيرها ازعجني جدا يا
عبد الرحمن وبعدين وصلت الى معتقلين لا
زالوا قائمين البريجا
والمؤتمر الرهيب اللي يسميها هنا زي اتش
داعي كما هو كامل يعني
لم يدمر
والشيء اللي
خلاني مدعور وارتعش المقابر واحنا نسموه
في شمال افريقيا الجبابين جبانه جبانه هذا
اسم مغاربي يعني مقبره
شبانه المفرد والجبابين اللي هي يعني
مقابر
على مدى البصر
قبور
فرجعت البنغازي وانا وانا والله يا عبد
الرحمن لا ابالغ كنت ارتعش ومدعور
شفت الموت عيني عينك
رجعت
وبعدين اكتشفت شيء اخرين كان مهمين في هذا
في هذا التحقيق
اللي انا 80% ما كنتش نعرفه
تحصلت الفين سنه 2012
على ارشيف الجنرال الدموي اللي هو خلف
انا سميته عباده وممكن تسالني تقولي ليش
سببين
عضو نظريه الاباده الحديثه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
رافائيل يمكن هذا هذا فقيه وعالم
قانوني بولندي كان اشرف على مؤتمر للامم
المتحده
ضد الاباده طبعا الحلفاء كانوا من حقهم
انه كانوا عندهم رغبه انهم يوروا ببشاعه
النازيه وغيرها واللي سبب طبعا وجيه
فقال ان
الاباده لازم نحددها بشكل قانوني ونضبطها
مش كل واحد صار له شيء مشكله تقول هذا
عباده قال اولا
لازم يكون فيه
نيه
انت انشنالتي باللغه الانجليزيه
ثانيا
تحطيم الحياه
يعني اوجه الحياه العضويه والثقافيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وابدالها
بالمستعمر او المهيمن
انا طبعا دورت
لقيت رسائل في الارشيف الايطالي اللي تقول
احنا والله احنا هدفنا
ان
نقضي هؤلاء
المسلمين والعرب
حتى لو ادى الى القضاء عليهم كلهم لان
احنا مستقبل الامه الايطاليه هو اللي على
النحل وهذا اهم شيء
هذا طبعا
ولقيت طبعا رسائل اخرى تؤكد هذا
وبعدين
الموتى يا عبد الرحمن من يعني ثلثين هم
ماتوا ثلثين الناس من 110 الف
يعني يعني ستين ولا سبعين الف ماتوا
المعتقلات بشكل محدد
ولما لما سالت نقول لهم ليش صار يا عمتي
وعمي يقولوا لي يا ابني احنا قطعنا من
قطعنا اللي هو مثنى اللي باللهجه البدويه
الليبيه اقطعنا من الشر والبركه
الشر والمرض
فاللي صار اني
اصريت ان اسم الشر يكون في عنوان الكتاب
مثلا سميته الاباده الجماعيه في ليبيا شر
وهي اسمها اي عربي حيفهم كلمه السر لكن
بالنسبه للمعتقلين يا عبد الرحمن ماذا
تعني تعني ان الموت الجماعي في المعتلات
الفاشيه من الجوع والمرض المفروض عليهم
وايضا نفق حيواناتهم والجانب حتى مهم كثير
من العرب يقفزوا على الاشياء هذه هذا مهم
جدا
ان لما لان كان ينظر للحيوان خاصه يعني مش
غير في الجزيره العربيه عندنا يعني ناسنا
في ليبيا بالذات
الناس اللي هم الباديه وكذا
الابل هي زي الانسان
زي الانسان انا اذكر ان الروائي الليبي
العبقري ابراهيم الكوني عند روايه اسمها
اعتبر على طارق انسان يعني بدوي وجمل بحري
هذا نوع من الابل في ليبيا نقول المهاري
والمفرد
ومحبتهم وسرقتهم مع بعضهم
تكتشف ان حتى علاقتهم بالحيوان هي علاقه
انسانيه مختلفه على قضيه ان الحيوان هو من
اجل بني ادم وتقتل وتاكل منه وتدمره زي ما
دمروا الحيوانات في ليبيا دمروا في امريكا
في العبادات سكان الاصليين حيوان الملايين
بامريكا فجاءت الى هذه الفكره قلت
بناء على على
الشروط اللي بضعها رافائيل يمكن
اللي في شيئين اخرين يعني يعني كملا
الحلقه التحقيق
اللي اخذ فتره طويله يعني عقد تقرير من
خمس سنوات بعدها من غربله ويعني والتمحيص
ما هو الصحيح ما هو غير صحيح ما هو الاكيد
ما هو غير الاكيد 16 سنه عشر سنوات من
الدراسه الميدانيه والارشيفيه وخمس سنوات
من البحث التمحيص 15 سنه بعدين يعني
ربك ابتسم لي يمكن الاشراف وبركتهم لحقتني
في امريكا في 2012
استطعت الحصول على ملفات
الدموي
اللي اشرف على على
المعتقلات وعلى الاباده
ست كرتونات
وكان عندنا كنز الدنيا
كنت يعني انظر لهم ونقول انا خلاص وصلت
الجنه ربك ارحمني ام كريم معي
فقعدت اقراها
كانت مرعبه
ومتعجرفه وفيها تفاصيل طبعا مهمه على
الاماكن الاخرى ولكن في ايضا كذب
يعني
هذا مهم
الحلقه الاخيره في الاكتشاف وهذا هو
التحقيق وانا لم اكن ادري اي شيء عنا
كنت مره ناكر عيني كنت اقرا في مجله
باللغه العربيه اصدرها صح في ليبي
مدعوم يعني زي ما تقول هي ايطاليا لم
تمانع بعد التاريخ الدموي انا عطى الصحبه
ليبيا الحق
في اصدار اسمها ليبيا المصوره اسمها فخري
المحيش ورجل كان يعني رجل حصيف
كان يعطي الاشياء اللي يبغاها الطليان
وكان في نفس الوقت يعطيه صوره
مساحه الشعراء للدباء الاخبار
وانا اقرا في
مجلاتات ليبيا المصوره
وجدت واحد من عتاد القاده النازيين جورينج
هذا من اقرب الناس الى هتلر كان رئيس
السلاح الجوي
وقاده الكبار في النازيه وجدت صورتها في
طرابلس ايام الحكم الايطالي هذا شنو يدير
غادي شو يعمل هذا
كنت
حصيف وهادي لا تقفز على الواقع شو يعني
هذه يمكن مجرد مصادفه انا طبعا للاسف
الشديد انا اقرب الفرنسي واعرف الايطاليه
جيدا ولكن الالماني عبد الرحمن
اللي صار اني
سالت بعض زملاء لي في عن طريق النت قلت
لهم في حد يشتغل على المراسلات النازيه
الفاشيه
والعلاقات مع المستعمرات
ففيه صديق قال لي فيه استاذ في مؤرخ
الماني شاب محترم جدا يدرس في ايرلندا
اسمه
لا اذكر الان اسم الله عليك المهم فيه ان
ارسلت له ايميل قلت له انا فلان فلان
الفلاني الحقيقه ابغى اتاكد منك اذا كان
في اي معلومات او هل في اي اشياء اخرى انا
على غير درايه بها مما يتعلق باهتمام
القاده النازيين
بتجربه المعتقلات وتوطين
الفقراء والفلاحين الطليان في ليبيا
وهنا جاءت المفاجاه يا عبد الرحمن
قال لي لا هذا جزء من قطره في في تيار
كبير
قال لي ان الحقيقه القاده النازيين لم يكن
معجبين بالتجربه البريطانيه او التجربه
الفرنسيه كانوا معجبين بالتجربه الايطاليه
واعتقدوا ان اهم شيء عملوا طليانه فرغوا
السكان من شرق ليبيا بسبب المعتقلات
وهذا شبيه به هو اهتمامهم بتوطين فلسطين
15 مليون الماني في شرق اوروبا
كفضاء حيويه
خمس دراسات معمقه
واكتشفت ان شيء مذهل
ان احنا العرب
وحتى الدراسات التي تركز على المركزيه
الاوروبيه المحرقه ان هي اهم شيء وانا نشا
الاخرى عباره عن يعني ضحايا حروب
زي ما اقول بعض الاساس الامريكان ضباب
الحرب فاقفوا يعني هذه الصيف الحروب
يعني هذه
في كل الحروب والفضائر
لما بعت لي اكتشفت ان في شيء اكبر
وهو ان قبيل
المحرقه هذا كان عامل مهم
ان فجاه ان احنا العرب المسلمين في الحاله
الليبيه
الفاشيه
كانت جزء من تجربه الليبيه اللي هي شبيهه
بالمحرقه اليهوديه وايضا تعطي نوع من
الترابط والتاثير المتبادل
رجعت بعدين الى استاذه فيلسوف اهم فيلسوفه
معاصر المانيه امريكيه هيحنى
اللي هي كتبت كتاب مهم جدا اصول الشموليه
وقالت ان
ان المحرقه اليهوديه وهي طبعا كانوا مضحيه
النازيه مهاجره لامريكا
قالت انه انه تعرف المحرقه لابد ان تدرس
بعمق الفضائع الالمانيه
والفرنسيه
في افريقيا
في الكونغو بالذات في الكونغو اللي هو
قاتل حوالي 10 مليون في الكونغو
الحاليه هذه
وقالت انه
المحرقه المؤرخين العلماء الاوروبيين
والغربيين يجب انه يهتموا بالفضائع اللي
هي سبقت المحرقه
اللي هي الكونغو وبعدين طبعا
وانا لاني اكتشفت حاجه رهيبه جدا
قلت ان الحاله الليبيه ايضا الحالات
الثلاثه طبعا الحاله الجزائريه ايضا عنيفه
ومرعبه لكن علاقتها بالمحرقه الان انا
اطرح ليس اعاده كتابه
المعتقلات الفاشيه وتاريخها المنسي
والمخفي انا الان حاولت اني اكتب هذا
الكتاب لاعاده كتاب التاريخ الفاشيه وايضا
الاباده في المحرقه اليهوديه نفسها
والضحايا الخمسه ملايين الاخرين اللي هم
قتلوا سواء الغجر سواء
الكاثوليكيين الاشتراكيين المثليين
المعاقين اللي هم يعني يعني قضوا عليهم
وهذا الان خالق ضجه كبيره ليس فقط في في
امريكا ولكن ايضا في اوروبا
بدات الكتاب
يطرح على انه هو يعني مدرسه جديده في عدد
التفكير في في الاباده
وبربط الاباده في اوروبا بالاباده اللي
صارت في العالم في افريقيا وما فيها
الحاله الليبيه اللي هي العربيه اللي ممكن
يعني غريبه شويه لكن مشهوره يا عبد الرحمن
بس
ما نشرت كتابي الاصوات المهمه الجامعات
العريقه في امريكا في هارفرد
في كولومبيا يا سيدي في براون
عندها مركز دراسات
الاباده المقارن مركز دراسات
الحالات اللي بعدها المقارنه او المقارنه
فانا صارت عندي عاده لا يعني مش مشاكسه
لكن حبيت اعرف اقول لهم حد يعرف على
المعتقلات الفاشيه في ليبيا
يقولوا لي يعني
هل كان في معتقالات
والحقيقه كانوا اللطيفين وكانوا مفتاحين
يا عبد الرحمن ما كانوش يعني متاسفين ولا
شيء لكن اكتشفت انه شيء رهيب ان الطليان
والحقيقه فشل القيادات الليبيه
الدراسات الليبيه فانها حتى تكتب عليها
لا العرب عارفين عنها لما يعرفوا نجحت
عمليه الكفر عمليه الاسكات
فهذا ادى الى ان
يعني زاد اكد لي يعني طرح علي سؤال جديد
بشكل قانوني وبشكل حصيف وبشكل منضبط على
المعتقلات وتاريخها
وتاثيراتها
ولكن ايضا سالت نفسي سؤال جديد
وكيف هذا من المسؤول عن الاسكات في
الدراسات الغربيه
مدرسات الاوروبيه
والدراسات ما بعد الاستعمار
هل هو يعني بسبب
عفوي ومن غير نيه والا فيه ايضا في عوامل
عده الى اسكات وردم واخفاء هذا التاريخ
الدموي العنيف
طبعا اكتشفت ان في اطاله لعند الان
ليس فقط لا يدرسوه الموضوع هذا فيه ثلاثه
واربعه مؤرخين مهمين والاخرين لا يهتموا
بالموضوع اطلاقا
ثانيا
قلت يعني في مدينه تمثال وذري تمشيط هذا
الداء الرجل الدموي ملطخه بالدماء احد
الجنرال وايضا هو عبد الرحمن لان عكس
النازيه النازيه طبعا زعمائها وقادتها
صارتها محاكمه ضد الانسانيه جرائم ضد
الانسانيه لم يحدث هذا للجرائم الايطاليه
المعتقلات وغيرها وحتى الاعتذار اللي حصل
عليه القذافي ومهم حتى الجزائر لم يحصلوا
عليه كان شويه غامض
يعني اعتذار وكذا ولكن لم يفصل في شو صار
وكذا وهو قبل ايده وقال حب على راسها وعلى
خشبه وقال له
خلاص انا فتحت عكا انا هزمت الاستعمار
وهذا وكذا فكانت في كلفه شويه وحتى
التعويض كان لا يليق بالناس يعني انا صرت
بعد ما سمعت من الناس اللي كانوا في
المؤتمرات الاحياء النساء والرجال
وخاصه نحكي لك على قصه يعني لعند الان
يعني تدمي قلبي سيده ليبيه عجوز في
ثمانينيات ولكن ذاكرتها ممتازه كانت تبكي
لي وتغني لي في نفس الوقت تقول لي يا ولدي
اللي ما صار لحد قلت لها
بس قاعد تستمع لهذا باحتراما وتبجيلا لها
وتغني شويه وتبكي لي شويه
واحد اعطاني يعني قصدي عشان اوريك كيف انا
صرت انا الان في الاول كنت محايد ومنضبط
لابد من العلم والمعرفه وعدم لكن بعدين
قعدت الكتاب قلت انا الكتاب لازم يكتب من
وجهه نظر هؤلاء الناس اللي هم ما عندهمش
اي تاريخ
وانكار انهم تاريخ اصلا وليهم اصوات
واراده فاعله
فصارت هذا هو الان فكره الكتاب
بعد الخمس سنوات هذه صرت اكتب
وكتبته والحقيقه انا لم يعني مش بشكل
عفوي وانا بشكل
انا كتبت طبعا
الناس اللي كانوا يورو لي روايه شفاهيه
تقريبا اللي عندي حوالي 300 يعني مقابله
اللي اعطوها لي الناس واللي انا عملتها
بنفسي يعني
وجدت الاتي ان
ان الكتاب
ابغاه انه يكون
في تشويق شويه للقارئ لان الموضوع ثقيل
ومحبط القلب وهمه وغم
[موسيقى]
كنت خليني يعني والله من غير وعي عبد
الرحمن كتبت كقصه
قصه
الجهاد لاكتشاف الحقيقه
وصار قالوا لي الناس قالوا لي الحقيقه رغم
انهم مزعج لكن ما تقدر تحطها يعني لازم
تكمله لانه هو كانه هو زي الروايه وبعدين
صديق لي
عزيز جدا هو كاتب محترم قال لي قاعد اتنفس
ايش قصته عالي هذا منين جاء بعدين قال
اكتشفت ان انت بدات في الثانوي بالادب كنت
يعني علاقتك بالادب قويه كنت الحقيقه هذا
صحيح لكن ايضا عندما تنغمس وتتعمق وتفهم
طريقه الثقافه العربيه شفاهيه
في الكلام وفي الروايه انت تصير انت تصير
راويه من غير ما تشعر
يعني الكتاب الحقيقه تطور من غير انا اقول
لازم اكتبه بالصوره هذه والا المعلومه
عندي اطلاقا 80% من هذا الكتاب
اكتشفته عن طريق التحقيق
وكنت دائما اركز على هذه الكلمه يا عبد
الرحمن قلت انا احقق في جريمه جماعيه وانت
كمحقق موضوعي منصف تبحث عنها الحقيقه
وبالتالي
اضبط روحك خليك منضبط
وكون وكون حصيف مع الدليل والقرائم
والحقائق ولكن تعرف نفس الوقت لما دليل او
او موضوع
دمر والا الغي ولا اخفي من حقك انت كباحث
انت تقول نفترض هذه الصوره هي الموجوده او
هذه طريقه موجوده وبعدين
قلت انا مش حنكمل بس الليبيين والعرب
والمسلمين انا ابغاك بل العالم
والحاله الليبيه لن تكون حاله فريده ولا
حاله وحيده هي جزء من حالات اخرى في
اوروبا وفي افريقيا وفي العالم نفسها
وبدات وانهيت الكتاب
بطريقه طبعا مشاكسه للزملائي الامريكان
قلت انا الان عايش في امريكا واستاذ
امريكي
كيف كانت صوره هذه الموضوع بالنسبه
للثقافه
والفكر والجامعه الامريكيه فاخترت ثلاث
مواضيع لتحقيق فيها النيوي
قراءه كل المقالات من 1911 1943 الموضوع
ولقيت حوالي خمسه وسته مقالات
كان فضيحه كلها توجد الاستعمار الايطالي
ومنحازه لي
بعدين الارشيف الامريكي
في كانت معلومات مهمه وكان في دبلوماسي
امريكي في روما قنصل كان جيد موقفه جيد
جدا موضوع بعدين يا سيدي العزيز في مجله
امريكيه شعبيه يمكن سامع بها
قديمه من بدايه القرن العشرين
فشفت كيف
نظره هذه المجله على العالم المستعمر او
العالم غير الاوروبي
ووجدت فيها تحقيقات في غايه الطرافه بعدها
الافلام
لان في العالم العربي دائما احنا نفصل
التخصصات وهذه اعتقد كارثه علينا الان
لازم
ننظر الى تداخل
التخصصات مع بعضها وهذا وهذا يعطينا روعه
اشمل واعماق
واخيرا طبعا
نظرت الى الاساتذه التاريخ والعلوم
السياسيه اللي كتبوا على الفاشيه
الايطاليه
كانت كلها تتماشى
حتى بشكل خفيف مع مع السرديه الفاشيه
والايطاليه
واكتشفت انه في تركيز على شيئين هذا طبعا
اكتشاف ان
الجدل المهيمن
وهو ان هناك فاشيه ناسيه وحشيه لان الشعب
الالماني شعب قاسي وعنيف ولهذا ادى الى
الى مذابح والى اباده الشعب الايطالي
متاعين تخافه واوبرا وبيتزا
ودمهم خفيف
مش معقوله يديروا للشيء هذا غير غير معقول
زائد انهم كانوا كويسين مع اخواننا
واخواتنا اليهود
وبالتالي حتى الاستاذ العظيم اللي انا
احبها جيدا
قالت لم يكن هناك سؤال
معادله الساميه في ايطاليا طبعا متعرفش
الموضوع ليبيا
فاللي صار بعدها واضح انه بالمقابل فيه
روحات الاباده في الادبيات الاباده اللي
هي مهم يا عبد الرحمن الكتابات على
الاباده والمحرقه هي كتابات في الادبيات
الفلسفيه والفنيه والنظريه الغربيه مهيمنه
هذا الموضوع الاثير
في الدراسات الاف الكتب والمعارض والمتاحف
والنصب التذكاريه في كل مكان فموضوع مهيب
اضطريت اني انا ايضا اني ازور المتحف
المحرقه ويمكن اكون المسلم والعرب الوحيد
يحملوا وكان كنت بقولهم في نفسي احنا في
الموقف هذا احنا وانتم في الهواء سوا في
الهم سوا
هناك النازيه والثقافه الالمانيه اللي هي
مهيمنه
وتؤدي الى الاباده وهناك فاشيه حميده واقل
شرا
اقل شرا
وهذه هذا
التماثل والتفكير مهيمن بطريقه لا تتصورها
فانا وجدت نفسي اني انا لازم اشاكس وان
ادمر هذه الاسطوره
واعتقد واتمنى يعني
اتمنى ان هذا الكتاب يثير جدل
جدل هم لما يتعودوا عليه
واتمنى في العالم العربي ان الموضوع هذا
الكتاب اللي هو ارهقني وانهكني وهلك حيلي
ان الناس تقرا خلال العشر سنوات الاخيره
تستوعب تناقشه ويمكن تستوعب انه هو
الحقيقه مش على بس المعتقللات اللي صارت
1929 1904 لا هو على الصراع على الذاكره
والصمت
وان هذا ان احنا يمكن يعطينا مفاتيح
لاعاده كتابه تاريخ الدوله بس احنا نحتاج
تاريخ مجتمعاتنا
وهذا يبدو لي انه رغم انه هو في دراسات
جيده العربيه كثيره لكن يمكن يكون هو
طريقه فريش جديده
واجنده للبحث العلمي باسئله جديده يمكن في
القرن هذا ان احنا كعرب بالذات
لمهتمين بفهم مجتمعاتنا
وتداخلاتها وتاريخها مش تاريخ الماضي في
الماضي عبد الرحمن انا اسميه تاريخ الحاضر
تاريخ الحاضر يا عبد الرحمن في تاريخ
تقليدي اللي هو التاريخ
السنوات والاسامي
والشخصيات
وفي تاريخ اخر اكثر تعقيدا واكثر اهميه
لنا اللي هو اصول
وجذور كيف بدات هذه
الصراعات
وكيف استمرت الصراع عليها حتى الان
الكتاب حاولت اني اطبق هذا على كتابي
فحاولت اني انظر 1929
وبعدين المرحله الاستعماريه الاستقلال
المرحله سبتمبر القذافي والان حتى
عوده الرموز
تاريخيه في الجدل الان القائم
وانا اعتقد هذا يمكن ليس حاله ليبيه
محدوده ولكن ربما يعطينا يعني اسئله جديده
ورؤى جديده على اعاده كتابه تاريخ الحاضر
في العالم العربي كله الله يعطيك العافيه
يعني مثل هذه المجهودات وهذا البحث وهذا
يعني هو اللي يعطي
يعني هذه الروح الجديده في البحث وحتى
رايي كيف ترى العالم من خلال زاويتك انت
مو لازم انه كيف يرى الاخر
فحس كل الكتب وكل الاشياء اللي ذكرتها
بتكون في نشره هذه الحلقه باذن الله بس
انا باخذ الحين تواريخ كذا سريعه تفضل
الحين احنا مرينا
بالاباده
وبنتقل الى
انتهاء الاستعمار
والحلفاء
زحفوا بعد حرب العالمين زحفوا هزموا
الجيوش الالمانيه والايطاليه اخذوا برقه
اخذوا المنطقه الغربيه
نعم والفرنسيين جاؤوا من من تشاد واخذ
الفزان
صارت تحت اداره هم في العاده يعطوا فيه
اسم لطيف اداره الاداره البريطانيه
والاداره الفرنسيه
التقسيم هذا
يعني هو اداره نقدر نسميها هو طبعا
التمييز بالاتين غائم لكن
انا اعتقد ان
الفرنسيين كان دائن عنده حلم انه
على البيع احمد سيف نصر القائد هذا
المجاهد الكبير ورفض رفض انه يعطوه حتى
طلعوا له طوابع وطلعوا له كذا
وكان المنهج التعليمي هو المنهج الفرنسي
من الجزائر حتى بعض الشباب الصغار كانوا
يدرسوا فيهم في امتحانات ياخذوا امتحانات
في الجزائر في نظام الفرنسي او لعند الان
بعد سقوط نظام سبتمبر الفرنسيين حاولوا
يعودوا بقوه الى الى فزان ويلعب بدور اكبر
لانه يعتقدوا انهم هم النظام القذافي
ازاحهم من جزء مهم من ليبيا ويعتقدون انهم
جزء ولهذا سركوزي وعلاقته شائكه مع
القذافي دخل بقوه في في ضرب النيتو
للجيش الليبي ولا نظام القذافي طيب الان
كان هذا هذه الدولتين اخذت هذه الاقاليم
الثلاثه اختلف شيء في هذه الفتره الى حد
الى الاستقلال واحد وخمسين عن والله هي
شوف هذه المرحله تحتاج دراسه اعمق لكن
الذي اعرفه عنها ان
الاداره البريطانيه عملت بالتنسيق مع
القيادات السيد محمد ادريس السنوسي
والكيانات الطرابلسيه في اعاده بعد مرحله
دمويه وحروب وتدمير بنغازي ثلاث اربع مرات
بداوا في يعني
بناء البنيه تحتيه في التعليم في الاداره
في عوده المنفيين والمهاجرين في اشياء
ايجابيه كثيره حصلت في ليبيا ولكن ايضا
كانت الضغوطات والمماحات بيناتهم ايش نعمل
بليبيا زي ما حكيت لك في بدايه حديثنا
اتفاق القياده الليبيه في الغرب بالذات مع
الامير محمد السنوسي ادريس السنوسي كان
مهم لان هو التوافق اللي براي اللي خلق
الاستقلال ليبيا وايضا رفض السيد احمد سيف
الناصر
للاستقلال او الانفصال بفزان
قبل الاماره السيد
محمد
ادريس السنوسي وايضا القيادات والترابطيه
بدات في التاجيج وتعبئه الناس ضد مشروع
تقسيم اللي هو
كانه من قبل هذه العوامل يعني
ادت الى الى
افشال المشاريع التقسيم في ليبيا وايضا
دعمت مشروع الاستقلال وخاصه هو كان مشروع
توافقي لان السيده ادريس صار ملك ليبيا
ولتوازن لخلق توازن بين بين الاقاليم
الثلاثه عملوا شيء طبيعي نظام فدرالي لكن
دستوري في مجلس شيوخ مجلس نواب وكانت فيه
الحقيقه مؤسسات بدعم الامم المتحده اللي
بعثت واحد مندوب اسمها
سعد الليبيين في في مساله هذه
وعملوا دستور كثير انا اعتقد والليبينغ
يتفقوا معي كثيرا يعني كان دستور محترم
بمقاييس الخمسينيات وستنيات طبعا الان شيء
اخر لكن هذيك الفتره مهمه هناك ناس لحتى
الان يدعون الى عوده الدستور السابق اللي
هو
الليبيه المتحده
في طبعا فيه الان جدل كبير ولم يحسب حتى
الان هناك ناس يدعونا نظام الفيدرالي
لاسباب
جهويه واسباب ما يسموه تهميش الشرق ليبيا
ورقه
وهناك طبعا ناس يقولون القذافي من
من
اكثر اخطاء نظامه انه هو لم يبني مؤسسات
او
يعني
يؤدي الى كتابه دستور جديد
وبالتالي عندنا دستور عظيم ومهم
في اللي هو طبعا
نقح في 63 اراد عمليه تلقيح وتعديل
يقولون احنا نعود اليه الليبيين ايضا
اخرين يقولوا لا هذا كان مهم في تلك
الفتره لكن ممكن في جوان ناخذه منه لكن
احنا نحتاج كتابه
دستور جديد كان فيها دستوريه منتخبه بعد
2012 للاسف انا مع كل احترامي ليهم لا
اعتقد ان في فتره الحروب الاهليه وعدم
الاستقرار الوقت مناسب انك تكتب
برجع الى
51 استقلال
ليش شو اللي دفع لي بانها تستقل قبل تونس
والجزائر رغم انها كانت يعني اكثر فقرا
الحركه الليبيه قويه الاستقلاليه سواء
الليبيين اللي كانوا يطالبوا بشكل مستمر
ولعب ودور سياسي واعلامي مهم المطالبه
والاستقلال
واشعال
واستمراريه القضيه الليبيه في حق تقرير
المصير تحالف الامير محمد ادريسنوسي مع مع
القياده الحلفاء وبدايه الانجليز لعب دور
كتير من ليبيين يختلفوا مع هذا لكن لا بد
من تختلف معه كان اللي يدور ان وجد حليف
خارجي في المساله والانجليزي كانت عندهم
ايضا مش حبا في ادريس كانوا يبغوا بعد
ثوره
بعد قلاقا في في في
مصر يبحثوا كانوا عن عن
يعني امن واستقرار وجهه نظرهم لشرق ليبيا
على وجودهم في مصر وبالتالي كان التحالف
بالنسبه لهم هذا مهم
هم مش حبا في عيون الليبيين ولا السيد
محمد ادريس السنوسي كانوا يبغوا ايضا
استقرار استراتيجي وتحالف استراتيجي يضمن
وجودهم في مصر
وقناه السويس بالنسبه لهم هذه القضيه
محوريه بالنسبه لوجود الامبراطوريه
البريطانيه بشكل عام
الشيء الاخر يا عبد الرحمن
بالاضافه الى
النضال المهاجرين
التحالف السياسي
والحلقه الاخيره
اتفاق الليبيين على الاستقلال
كيان موحد كما كانت الغرب كما كانت الدوله
القرانيه كما كان كان من قبل في القرون
الاولى
ظهور وعي سياسي
ما بين شرح عديده في المناطق الثلاثه هذه
الجهه الثلاثه ساعد في اعطاء القضيه
الليبيه وايضا حصل توافق
الحلفاء
في فتره
النضال
الشعوب اللي هو مستعمره من اجل الاستقلال
وجدوا انهم الانسب انهم يضافوا على نظام
الى حد كبير
يعني متحالف معهم
وبالتالي وجدوا ان هذه فكره جيده
واستوعبوها والحقيقه
القياده الامريكيه كانت دائما تلعب ان
الاوروبيين هذوما يعني سمعه ونويتهم سيده
وموسخه يعني يعني تاريخهم لانهم مستعمر
الشعوب احنا غير غير
وهذا كيف صار في الاول كانت تحالف مع
بريطانيا لكن بعدين صارت حاله مع مع
امريكا واكتشاف النفط كان محوري
ثوره 23 يوليو في مصر
خوف خوفهم اكثر وخلاهم يهتموا باستقرار
باستمراريه الملا المملكه الليبيه ولكن
المملكه الليبيه الى حد كبير وهذا شيء
حقيقه لازم نعترف بها كانت مملكه دستوريه
تحديثيه تعليم فيها قفص قفزات نوعيه وكانت
ايضا فيها الى حد كبير لا اقول ديمقراطيه
نظام ديمقراطي لكن مجلس شيوخ مجلس نواب
منتخب
وكان فيها مش صحافه مثلا في احد قليل من
المساحه ولهذا ليبيا في
نهايه الستينيات
يعني كانت دوله عربيه
قفزت خبزات نوعيه في التعليم والتحديث
وكانت طرابلس من اجمل المدن
البحر المتوسط
فهذه الجوانب الايجابيه في جوانب طبعا
سلبيات لازم الواحد ينكرها القواعد عدم
فهم التغيرات الاعيان والفئات العليا
المجتمع على على الاقتصاد وعلى الدوله في
اشياء اخرى ممكن واحد يرضي معاها لكن لابد
من انصاف الاستقلال ولكن من غير ان انا لا
اتفق انا اتفق مع الانصاف والموضوعيه لان
فتره كانت مزدهره وفتره ايجابيه وتحديثيه
لكن يجب ان لا ننظر لها من ناحيه رومانسيه
او مثاليه لانها كانت ايضا فيها عيوب
وفيها
اشكاليات مؤسساتيه وخيارات ادت الى الى
استمرار فيما بعد حتى بعد 69 هل كان
استقلال حقيقي ام سوري انا اعتقد كان
استقلال حقيقي ولكن مليء بالتناقلات
بعد المرحله الاستعمار الاستيطاني الابادي
العنيف
حتى رغم انه فيه نواقص كان انجاز
انا بالنسبه لي
ولدت بعد الاستقلال ولكن تعلمت في دوله
ليبيا الحديثه
والسبعينيات فيما بعدها بعدم سبتمبر ايضا
ولهذا
الجيل اللي قبلي والاجيال اللي بعدي احنا
يعني هذا بالنسبه لنا كان انجاز كبير
وكانوا الليبين فخرون ان اثارتهم دوله
المملكه الليبيه انا سمعت دوله الاستقلال
وانا اعتقد من ناحيه هذه هو انجاز وخاصه
توافق اللي نعتبر اكثر يعني شيئا لكن
هناك مشاكل
القواعد الاجنبيه
التركيز النخبوي عدم السماح بالاحزاب
يعني عدم
التسامح مع القيادات المعارضه السيد بشير
السعداوي سفر من ليبيا واخذوا منه جنسيته
وانتهى انه مات المنفى
في جوانب طبعا
لهذا قلت لك ان انه كان انجاز ولكن مليء
بالتناقضات هذا يعني بالتناقضات ايش قصه
انقلاب 61
انقلاب
اللي طالب فيهم الملك ادريس
انه ياخذون عقوبات لكنه صارت عقوبات مخففه
في بعضهم يقولون
اغتيال ابراهيم الشلحي هو والحقيقه اغتيال
للسيد ابراهيم الشلح اللي هو مستشار
الملك محمد ادريس السنوسي الله يرحمها
سيدي ابراهيم الشلح هي عارفه من من طفوذه
وكان طبعا مستشاره
يعني دراع اليمنى
كان في صراع داخل الاسره الحاكمه ما بين
احفاد السيد
احمد الشريف السنوسي اللي هو مات عندكم في
الحجاز يتذكر هو نوفي ففيه نوع من التوتر
بين جناحيل الاسره السلوكيه السيد محمد
ادريس السنوسي اللي هو كان اكثر اعتدالا
واكثر ابراج ماتيه في السياسه وفي التعامل
مع القوه الدوليه والواقع والحقيقه لازم
ننصف السيد محمد ادريس السنوسي لان كان
يقود حركه عسكريه هزمت وبالتالي حتى
ادواتها وقدره على التفاوض كانت محدوده زي
ما قلت انا في كتاب الاول لكن كانت فينا
كنوع من التوتر
ما بين جناح وكانوا يعتقدوا ان ال الشلحي
اللي هم الوسقاء بالملك ادريس مستوحدين
على على
الملك وانه مغبونين فكان في نوع من التوتر
وانتهى طبعا
باغتيال المستشار الملك السيد ابراهيم
الشنفي والملك ادريس غضب من جناح واحفاد
وابناء وبنات
السيد احمد الشريف السنوسي وانافعهم في
واحات بعيده
هل ساهم باي شكل من الاشكال في تهيئه الجو
لانقلاب القذافي
سؤال وجيه والحقيقه لم افكر فيه من قبل
يحتاج الى نوع من التمحيص والتذكير فيه
لكن اعتقد ليس ليس عجيبا ان في بيان
الانقلاب او ثوره صارت ثوره الفاتحه كما
يقول اصحابها يا ابناء المدن يا ابناء
الباديه يا ابناء المدن العريقه يا احفاد
احمد الشريف وعمر المختار عن البيك تركز
معايا يا عبد الرحمن
ذكر سيد احمد الشريف السنوسي وذكر السيد
الشيخ الشهداء عمر المختار وهو هذا نوع هو
الحقيقه اضطهد العائله السلوكيه كما اضطهد
العائله سيف النصر للاسف الشديد وكثير من
النخب الاولى وانتقم منهم كثيرا لكن هو
بيحاول يقول ان انا مع المجاهدين وانا
سليل المجاهدين وانا امتداد ليهم
فتجد تعقيدات
وتوظيف الرمزي للقياده التاريخيه الليبين
حتى هذا اليوم عبد الرحمن
يتكلمون عن الحاضر من خلال الكلام على
الماضي على المرحله الاستعماريه والجهاد
انا هذا ازعم هذا وانا شو طبيعي لانك انت
تحكي على فتره التكوين وفتره عنيفه ولكن
فتره فيها تحولات واباده وعنف ومقاومه
وتواضع وتعاون وباندا وهكذا بس هذا هذا
الربط ما بين الاغتيال وايضا القذافي كيف
نجح القذافي في انقلاب ايش العوامل اللي
ساعدتها كانت في عوامل خارجيه داخليه
طبعا يحتاج ايضا الى دراسات عميقه في
عندنا بعض دراسات ولكن ليس بالعمق قد
تستغرب ليس هناك دراسه وافيه عن مسائل هذه
في كتب يا اما ايديولوجيه يا اما معه ضد
لكن باجتهادي
وانا طبعا
هذا موضوع ربما يحتاج مني اكثر من التفكير
وتدقيق والتمحيص
هناك عوامل ساعدت القذافي نظام الملكي
كان نظام ناجح من ناحيه التحديثيه من
ناحيه الرفاهيه من ناحيه التعليم من ناحيه
استقلال ليبيا ولكن
خفوته وسكوته
عن المرحله الاستعماريه والقواعد في في
عالم عربي يموج بحركات المنتظره الاستعمار
وعبد الناصر والقوميه العربيه والسؤال
القضيه الفلسطينيه واستغلال الجزائر 62
لليبيا لعبه فيها دور كبير اهلي وسياسي
خل النظام في حاله دفاع
واعتقد هذا مجرد حدث وليس عندي اي دليل
نظام
ركز على ليس على الجيش ركز على شربه القوه
المتحركه
كانت القوه البوليس اكثر تسليحا واكثر
يعني بعدد مساوي بالجيش الجيش كان صغير
ومش وليس ليس يعني بالحجم الكبير
والجيش ايضا كان مفتوح لفئات عديده من
الشعب
القذافي كان عند سواء نتفق معه كان قائد
كاريزماتي
كان عنده وعي متطور
كون تنظيم سياسي وبعد دخل طلب من بعض
اعضاء تنظيم السياسي يدخل الجيش انا لا
اقول انه انقلاب عسكري في حسب هذا القصر
النظر القذافي حسب ما نعرف الان كون تنظيم
سياسي في سبها في ثانويه سبها فيما بعد
اعداديه وثانويه
ولان النظام في هذاك الوقت يتلم يعني شرسه
والله والله عنيفه في قمل المعارضين
فسمحين بالانتقال الى مصراته بعد
مظاهره في سنه 58
وحسب ما قال في خطابات العديده وبعض بعض
زملائها
قرروا يعني ان التركيز على الانضمام للجيش
وقلب نظام الحكم
وكان مثالا الاكبر هو طبعا الرئيس عبد
الناصر هزم في حرب 48
في الفلوجه حوسر وبدا ينظر الى الفساد
والى المشاكل الموجوده في مصر وبدات
التفكير في قلب نظام الحكم هذا اعطى
الكذافي فكره ان من طالب مناقشه سياسي
عربي قومي عربي الى الى انه هو يركز على
نظام
الملكي طبعا كان شويه
كانت اكثر محاوله في الجيش الليبي ولكن
يبدو ان كان واحن ولما يعي بخطوره مجرد
فروخ ولا مجرد يعني هذا شباب يعني مطرفين
وكذا وحينتهي الموضوع
في هناك طبعا مقولات اخرى لم اجد دليل
عنها بيقول ان مثلا المرحوم الدكتور محمود
جبريل يوفرلي
في اطروحه الدكتوراه مهمه جدا يقول انه
الامريكان بطريقه غير مباشره وهذا مكشف
عنها عند الان في الارشيف الامريكي
اعرفوا ان النظام بدا يتاكل
وان الشباب الليبي اللي هم تعلموا في
المؤسسات التعليميه صاروا مدرسين مصريين
فلسطينيين
وبدات مقولات صوت العرب ومقولات المنطقه
والجزائر كلها بدات في يعني
تجدير تفكير القومي العربي وهو الحقيقه مش
غير في ليبيا بس في المنطقه العربيه كلها
لكن ليبيا يعني جاره من الناحيه الجزائر
ومن جهه هنا مصر فالتاتير كان قوي جدا
وايضا مؤسسات الجيش كانت مفتوحه الى القوه
المعارضه
فاللي صار انها اعتقد ان هناك جدل بيقول
ان
الحكومه الامريكيه غضت الطرف عرفت ان
النظام الان بدا يتاكل كافي فساد ايضا
مش بالفساد اللي هو موجود الان اللي هو
الان زي ما قال يا غسان
الاستاذ اللبناني اللي كان مبعوث ليبيا
غسان
ربية
دكتور غسان سلامه
قال انه اللي صار في ليبيا مش فساد في نحب
خصني انها كانت موجوده هذه في مقولات
بتقول انا يعني احتاج اني اتحقق من هذا ان
والدكتور محمود جبري لها ان في الاول لان
القذافي كان معادي بالشيوعيه
معاذ جدا
في السجون والباتيين
بالسجون
السعوديه ولما لا
يا عبد الرحمن ان ممكن هذا بطريقه غير
مباشر
قبلوا بتغيير نظام الحكم وخاصه في
البدايات كان شديده العداء الشيوعيه
والاتحاد السوفيتي
هذه
الطروحات
وهذه التفسيرات تحتاج تدقيق اكثر لان حتى
الان
لا نملك اي دراسه معمقه حصيفه
وعميقه على هل
المواضيع الشائكه ولكن للانصاف
النظام برغم قمعه للطلاب والمعارضين
وحتى نهايه السبعينيات برغم كل
العنف اللي صار
التخلص من قواعد الاجنبيه
توسيع دائره التعليم اكثر حتى من العهد
الملكي
التاكيد على العروبه وعلى الاسلام التاييد
القضيه الفلسطينيه
لم يخلقها القذافي عبد الرحمن هذه موجوده
ومتجدر في الشعب الليبي في القذافي مجرد
هو عبر عنها بعد فتره طويله ولكن للاسف
الشديد
الثمانينات وتسعينيات صارت موضوع اكثر
صارت تكتتونيه وعباره بطل هو استبداد اللي
هو في نهايه الامر يعني خلى حتى نظام
القذافي هذا اللي هو كان في جوانب ايجابيه
للمراه وجوانب ايجابيه للمجتمع والفئات
المهمشه والفقيره وغيرها في الاخير بدات
تتاكل
والنظام لم يستطيع تجديد داده مصطلح دادا
وهذا راسها
انا اتمنى ان الليبيين
ان ينظروا
بجوانب المتعدده للجيل الاستقلال وايضا
حتى والان مش مستعدين يعملوها لكن نقول
حتى سبتمبر نحتاج ان ننظر لها بهدوء ونقول
ما لها وما عليها وهذا يؤدي الى كثير ما
تصالح لان هناك شرائح من الشعب الليبي لا
زالت تعتبر من القذافي ونظام سبتمبر هو
نظام مميز واللي جانا منيته والمشكله
ودمروا
وانا اعتقد يعني نبض فكره الانتقام
انتقام النظام سبتمبر لانه هو يعني
سود سماعات النظام الملكي او الانتقام من
نخبه سبتمبر
او الانتقام من الناس اللي هم كانوا في
اللجان الثوريه وغيرها وغيره الانتقام لا
يبني الامم ولا يبني المجتمعات
لكن
الاعتراف بشريات الاختلاف
الاعتراف بالتعدد السرديات
الاعتراض بالتنوع
الثقافي والاجتماعي بلبل فكري ايضا هذا هو
اللي يحبني امه ويبني مجتمعات وللاسف
الشديد الصوره قادمه الان يا عبد الرحمن
لكن لا يعني اننا نفقد الامل
[موسيقى]
الله يعين كل اهلنا في ليبيا وان شاء الله
يعني يكون مستقبل افضل يا رب ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا شكرا
شكرا جزيلا عبد الرحمن شكرا لكم شكرا
لايمن الحمادي في اعداد الحلقه في التحرير
محمد نور الشمه التصوير ادم الشهراني
الهندسه الصوتيه محمد الحسن التلوين عبد
المجيد العطاس واداره الانتاج اصيل فرض
اداره محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نوره
السبيعي هذا فنجان احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه
لنشر التوزيع ننشر كل الانتاج بحب من
مدينه الرياض الاسبوع المقبل
القادم
الحين يوم بس انا عندي سؤال من اول
يوم غيروا بريطانيا لايطاليا اسم ليبيا
كيف تقبل اهل ليبيا يعني وكيف صار الان
اسم طبيعي هذا سؤال لم يسالني عليه اي احد
[موسيقى]
الطليان بداوا لما درت تحقيق في هذا
الموضوع اكتشفت انه في 1905 بداوا
يستخدموا ليبيا
لاسباب استعماريه وهو عنا احنا هذا الاسم
الروماني لليبيا وهم طبعا بحاولوا انهم هم
يحطموا التركه
العثمانيه الدوله الاسلاميه العثمانيه
تفهمني
وصاروا في ادبياتهم يقولوا ليبا ولكن في
سنه 1933
اعلنوا ان هذه ليبيا موحده الاقاليم
الثلاثه واسمها
الحقيقه كان دول مستعمره اخرى يعني حتى
العراق
يعني كانت ولايات عثمانيه
وسوريا الكبرى ولا لبنان جبل لبنان ولا
دوله لبنان
وما كان في اسرائيل كان في اسرائيل
بالتالي اللي صار انه الناس صارت الاسم
المحافله الدوليه تقولها اللي بين عاشوا
فتره الاستعماريه ايضا يقولوها صارت
متقبله ان هي اسمها ليبيا لكن انا دائما
اصر نقول من ناحيه الموضوعيه التاريخيه
الاسم ليبيا اسم حديث
يزعلوا مني كتير انا يا عبد الرحمن معلومه
صادمه معلومه اول مره اسمعها
لانك انت ضحيه كالاخرين ان هذا المشاع هذا
هو المعتاد
طيب في وحده من محاضرات حضرتها بس كنت
يعني ذكرتها بشكل سريع سريع بس قلت يمكن
فكانك وصفت شمال افريقيا بشكل مختلف عن
الشرق الاوسط
فهل منطقي اليوم لما نسمع مصطلح الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا لان فعلا شمال
افريقيا يختلف عن الشرق الاوسط ولا
لا لا هو هويتينا انا اعتقد ان انا بحب
بصراحه هذا اسم اوروبي غربي
سوف اقصد المندي مهمه لكن احنا احنا عالم
عربي واسلامي
وعندنا المشرق وعندنا المغرب
وبالتالي انا بالنسبه لي استخدام الالفاظ
واللغه مهم بقدر التحليل دافع والمنطلقات
مرات تصير نكرر فيها وكانها هي اشياء مسلم
بها وصارت حقيقه
وهذا في كل كتاباتي تجده
بس احنا تنوع تجاربنا العربيه حتى داخل
يعني لما تشوف السعوديه تجربه عسير تجربه
نجد تجربه الحجاز كيف تكون هذه الكيان
الموحد هذا طبعا يحتاج نوع من الهدوء
والانصات
ايضا شمال افريقيا
العرب والمسلمين شمال افريقيا وامازيغيها
جاهدوا ضد الاستعمار الاوروبي
في ليبيا تحديدا معركه كانت مهمه وهي ضد
الاستعمار الاوروبي وبالتالي لم يكن هناك
شريف حسين
وقضيه هذا الجاسوس البريطاني المستشرق
عمله يعني يعني علم
هذا لم يكن موجود النضال بالضبط
ولهذا طبعا
اخواتنا في المشرق والدافئ الشام كانوا
يركزوا على مساله في النضال ضد الاتراك
والعثمانيين هذه الاشكاليه مش موجوده في
شمال افريقيا يا عبد الرحمن تحديدا في
ليبيا لانه ينظر العثمانيين حاربوا معاهم
وهم مسلمين في نهايه الامر احنا كلنا
مسلمين
وكثير من الباحثين العرب يخلصوا على هذه
الحق على التنوع تاريخي وهذا يدل على انه
شويه يعني كسل كسل فكري
مش هذا هذا افضل من هذا ولا شيء بس نفهم
تنوع تركيباتنا وتحولاتنا يعني وهذا
يساعدنا ان نتعامل معاها بشكل اكثر وضوحا
وجديه طيب اخر حاجه يعني في كاس العالم
المغرب كانت مشاهير
فتسمع في بعض يعني اللقاءات يعني
المغربيين او المغاربه فكان يقولون انه
هذا فوز الافريقية كيف
يعني بس كنت اتساءل يعني هلو
فوز لاسيا يعني علاقتنا باسيا علاقه ما
يعني ما لها اي علاقه احنا اقدر اقول
مسلمين اقدر اقول عرب اقدر اقول سعوديين
اللي تبغى
في بعضهم يقول لك
انا اجد ان هذا انا جاوبت عليه في الكتاب
واذا كان ما عندكش ارسله اللي هو ما بعد
الاستعمار والقوميه وترحت هذا السؤال اللي
تعتذر حضرتك تطرح
هذا توظيف سياسي في الهويات
[موسيقى]
شوف
بشكل شمال افريقيا منطقه المغرب العربي
الاسلامي بشكل عام طبعا هي في افريقيا
وانا دائما اقول بدل ما نقول احنا عرب
القذافي في الاخير دارها بشكل احنا عرب
ومسلمين وافارقه
احنا الناس اللي جينا من الجزيره العربيه
وانا اماكن اخرى في اليمن وغيرها
واحتكينا مع السكان الاصليين اللي هم
البربر الامازيغ
ولكن ايضا انتزجنا مع الافارقه الاخرين
ثقافيين عائليه
يعني فكريا فقهيا وبالتالي بدل بدل تقول
انه والله احنا فارغه ولكن هذا نوع من
التوظيف السياسي اللي اللي اغراض انيه
لكن احنا يجب ان نتوقف ونقول احنا عرب
مسلمين وفارقه هم الجزيره ومن الشام وايضا
بعضنا يطلع على البحر المتوسط وهذه كلها
مستويات متعدده للهويه واحده الهويه
بعباره اخرى دائما احاجز ليست
يعني وجه واحد الهويه متعدده الاوجه انت
مثلا سعودي ومن عسير وتعيش في الرياض
والان في نيويورك ودراستي اريزونا وهذه
كلها الاشياء مع بعضها يعني قصدي انه انا
الاوان ان بدر التوظيف السياسي اننا نعترف
انه متعددين للوجه وهذا لا يقلل من حالتنا
ولا شيء هذا لانه احنا يعني تركيبتنا لها
تاثيرات متعدده وتعريف العربي والاسلامي
الان ليس بتعريف عرقي ولكن تعريف متراكب
ومترابط ومتشابك